[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اهلا بكم في حصاد
الليله معكم محمد كريشان وفي الوقت الذي
احدثكم فيه الان تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من رام الله بالضفه
الغربيه المحتله وهذا التوتر المتصاعد
خاصه بعد استمرار قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في محاصره بلده حواره لليوم
السادس على التوالي
الى العاصمه الايرانيه طهران التي وصل
اليها مدير الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
رفايال بروسي لاجراء لقاءات مع مسؤولين
ايرانيين تتناول القضايا العالقه في الملف
النووي الايراني
وهذه الصور تاتينا من العاصمه الامريكيه
واشنطن من البيت الابيض تحديدا حيث اجرى
الرئيس جو بايدن لقاء مع ضيفه المستشار
الالماني
ركز على حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
وتداعياتها
وفي مواضيع الحساد لهذه الليله
في توسيع لهجماتهم المستوطنون يستهدفون
بورين في نابلس وفد اوروبي يطالب من داخل
حوار بحمايه الفلسطينيين ومسائله
المهاجمين الاحتلال يمنع نشطاء فلسطينيين
واجانب من دخول البلده يقول للجزيره ان
الفلسطينيين يعانون جحيما وتهديدا لحياتهم
والمفوض السامي لحقوق الانسان يتهم
الاحتلال بتعمد استخدام القوه المميته
مع اقتتام منابرات اسرائيليه امريكيه
تحاكي ضرب منشات نوويه ايرانيه رئيس هيئه
الاركان الامريكيه في تل ابيب والبنتاجون
يقول انها تشمل تنسيق التصدي لما سماه
تهديدات ايران ومسؤولون امريكي يتحدث عن
سعي ايراني للحصول على منظومه اس 400
الروسيه لحمايه منشاتها من اي عمل
اسرائيلي
معارك السيطره في شرق اوكرانيا تحتدم
فاجنر تقول انها تحاصر مدينه بخموت
الاستراتيجيه وتطالب القوات الاوكرانيه
بالانسحاب منها بعيدا يبحث مع المستشار
الالماني تعزيز دعم اوكرانيا والبيت
الابيض يكشف عن مساعدات عسكريه جديده
الاصوات الاوروبيه المعارضه للعقوبات على
روسيا
عشيه احتجاجات جديده لقطاعاته النقابيه
اتحاد الشغل في تونس يتهم الحكومه باغلاق
ابواب المفاوضات وجبهه الخلاص تتمسك
بمظاهرات الاحد رغم المناعه الرئيس السعيد
يرفض اشراك الاجانب في اي مظاهرات ويجدد
المطالبه بالمحاسبه والامم المتحده تدعو
لحمايه الديمقراطيه في تونس وتجدد رفض
اعتقال اي شخص بسبب ارائه السياسيه
[موسيقى]
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا معكم اتهام الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل الحكومه باغلاق ابواب
المفاوضات والحوار ومضيه في احتجاجات يوم
غد وذلك اثر رفض السلطات التونسيه السماح
لجبهه الخلاص المعارضه بتنظيم احتجاجات
بعد غدا الاحد بدعوى شبهه التامر في مقاله
الجبهه ان قرار منع التظاهر التعسفي وباطن
ولن تستجيب له والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
في رايكم ما دلالات استمرار الحركه النقبي
والدعوه لمزيد من الاحتجاجات
64% اعادوا الامر الى اصطفاف من الاتحاد
ضد الخيارات السياسيه للسلطه بينما ادرج
36% المساله في اطار رفض السلطات التونسيه
اي مبادره حوار سياسي للاتحاد السعودي
هذا السؤال سيبقى كالعاده مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا
على الشاشه لقاء على المنصات الرقميه
يتجدد يوميا التطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربيه ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
بعد تسعير معظم المواد في الاسواق
بالدولار الجزيره ترصد يوميات اللبنانيين
بين سلع شحيحه واسعار تلتهب وازمه تابى
الحل
[موسيقى]
قريه بورين في الضفه الغربيه تمثل احدث
فصول هجمات المستوطنين فقد قال مسؤول ملف
الاستيطان في شمال الضفه الغربيه غسان
دغلس ان عشرات المستوطنين هاجموا منازل في
القريه واعتدوا على سكانها بالرشق
بالحجاره كما اطلقوا الرصاصه الحي في
الهواء ما الحق اضرارا بعدد من البيوت وقد
اكدت مصادر طبيه فلسطينيه عدم وقوع اصابات
خلال تلك الاعتداد
وقبل ايام البورين كانت حواره وما زالت
عنوانا لاقتحامات قوه الاحتلال وهجمات
المستوطنين وقد زار وفد من الاتحاد
الاوروبي والدبلوماسيون بلده حواره ودانوا
جرائم المستوطنين واجراءات الاحتلال فيها
وطالب الوفد الاوروبي خلال جولته
الميدانيه التي شملت قريه زعاتره بمحاسبه
المسؤولين عن تلك الجرائم في حق
الفلسطينيين
الى بيت الشهيد سامح الاقطش في قريه زعتره
الجنوبيه نابلسة جاء وفد الاتحاد الاوروبي
في اولى محطات جولته الميدانيه للوقوف عن
قرب على ما تعرضت له العائله من جريمه قتل
احد ابنائها برصاص المستوطنين الاحد
الماضي
الوفد الاوروبي اصطدم بهذه المشاهد في
بلده حوار المجاوره عشرات المنازل احرقت
ومئات المركبات لم يتبقى منها سوى هياكلها
الخارجيه
وخلال الزياره تعرض الوفد الاوروبي وممثله
مؤسسات حقوقيه لمحاولات التشويش من احد
المستوطنين
ذات بالنسبه لنا من المهم تحقيق المسائله
الكامله واحضار المعتدين الى العداله
والذين تعرضوا للخساره في ممتلكاتهم يجب
تعويضهم والاكثر اهميه هنا يجب وقف عنف
المستوطنين لانه اذا استمر ذلك فلن يكون
هناك مستقبل في هذا المكان اذ لا توجد
حمايه للفلسطينيين المدنيين ولا يمكن
العيش بسلام وحريه
وتزامنا مع الزياره قمعت قوات الاحتلال
مظاهره ناشطي سلام اسرائيليين ومنعتهم من
الوصول الى بلده حواره للتضامن مع سكانها
يجب ان يكون هناك موقف واضح وان يقول
مجتمع الدولي بمحاسبه اسرائيل على هاي
الجرائم وهذه هي يعني بين قوسين مستوطنين
ولكن الاساس هي الدوله اللي رعت هذا
الارهاب لدعمت هذا الارهاب واللي حمدت هذا
الارهاب بنيرانها وبمعداتها وقوف الوفد
الاوروبي على شهادات ضحايا جرائم
المستوطنين واجراءات الاحتلال العسكريه في
قريه زعتره وبلده حواره وما تحمله تلك
الجرائم من مشاهد تستدعي في نظر
الفلسطينيين تدخلا فوريا لحمايتهم واذا
كانت زيارته فود دوليه تاتي مؤقتا فان
الفلسطينيين يودعون شهدائهم بشكل شبهي
[موسيقى]
فقد شيعت جماهير بلده عزون في محافظه
قلقيليه جثمان الشهيد الفتى محمد سليم الى
مثواه الاخير تشييع صاحبه تمديد بجرائم
الاحتلال ومستوطنيه التي تستهدف الحجر
والبشر في جميع الاراضي الفلسطينيه دون
حسيب او رقيب سميره ابو شمالي الجزيره من
بلده حواره جنوبيه نابلس فلسطين
وفي مقابله مع الجزيره قال الامين العام
للامم المتحده انطوني غوتيريش انه لا بديل
عن حل الدولتين وان على الجميع ادراك ذلك
مشيرا الى ان الفلسطينيين يعانون جحيما
وتهديدا لحياتهم واضافت ان على المجتمع
الدولي التحرك بقوه لضمان ان يحظى القانون
الدولي بالاحترام
من الواضح ان حل الدولتين يعني انهاء
الاحتلال وقرارات الامم المتحده تنص على
ذلك لكن المجتمع الدولي ليس قادرا على
تطبيقها وهذه مشكله في نظام الحوكمه الذين
نعيشه هو نظام بلا مخالب وحتى ان وجدت هذه
المخالب كما هو الحال عن طريق مجلس الامن
فليست هناك اراده لاستخدامها وتطبيق
القانون بالقوه يجب ان نتحرك بقوه اكبر في
المجتمع الدولي لضمان ان يحظى القانون
الدولي بالاحترام
الاوضاع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه وغيرها من
القضايا المتعلقه باخر الاحداث في العالم
ستكون ضمن المقابله الكامله للجزيره مع
الامين العام للامم المتحده والتي ستاتيكم
لاحقا في الحصاد
هذا وقد قال المفوض السامي لحقوق الانسان
التابعه للامم المتحده فولتورك ان قوات
الامن الاسرائيليه استخدمت القوه المميته
ضد الفلسطينيين بشكل متكرر ووصف ترك ذلك
خلال اجتماعا لمجلس حقوق الانسان وصف
الوضع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
بالماساوي بالنسبه للفلسطينيين
ان الوضع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
ماساه ماساه للشعب الفلسطيني قبل كل شيء
ادى الاحتلال المستمر منذ اكثر من نصف قرن
الى اتساع نطاق نزع الملكيه وتعميق
الحرمان والانتهاكات المتكرره والخطيره
لحقوقهم بما في ذلك الحق في الحياه لا
يمكن لاحد ان يرغب في العيش بهذه الطريقه
او يتخيل ان اجبار الناس على العيش في
ظروف يائسه كهذه يمكن ان يؤدي الى حلا
دائم
معنى من رام الله الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي
الامين العام للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور برغوثي
هذا التصاعد للادانات الدوليه هل يمكن ان
يغير شيئا
هذا التصاعد في الادانات مهم لانه يظهر
انكشاف اسرائيل وطابعها العنصري الاجرامي
وعمل الارهابي الذي تقوم به ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني ولكنه لن يكون مؤثرا ان لم
يقترن باتخاذ اجراءات عقابيه ضد اسرائيل
لا بد من فرض العقوبات والمقاطعه على
اسرائيل حتى يتم ردعها كما قال الامين
العام للامم المتحده غوتيريش قال هناك
قرارات دوليه ولكن لا يوجد لهذه القرارات
مخالب واذا وجدت مخالب لا توجد اراده
لاستخدامها بسبب حمايه الولايات المتحده
لاسرائيل ولكن في الواقع انا اقول الامه
المتحده لديها مخالب ولكنها استعملت في
اماكن اخرى استعملت ضد العراق تستعمل ضد
فنزويلا تستعمل ضد ايران اما ضد اسرائيل
فلا تستعمل وهذا هو جوهر العقده في
المجتمع الدولي اليوم وهي ازدواجيه
المعايير واستخدام معايير مزدوجه كلما
تعلق الامر
الترجمه الحقيقيه للادانات التي سمعناها
والاستنكارات حتى تكون فعاله هو فرض
العقوبات والمقاطعه على اسرائيل لان
الفلسطينيين اليوم يتعرضوا لحرب استيطانيه
والذي يشن الحرب مستوطنون مستعمرون يجلسون
على مقاعد الحكومه الاسرائيليه ويحمي
هؤلاء المستعمرون المستوطنون جيش الاحتلال
نفسه
زياره مثل زياره الوفود الاوروبيه
دبلوماسيين وسفراء وغيرها هل يمكن ان تسهم
في مزيد الضغط في هذا الاتجاه الذي تشير
اليه الان
يمكن ان تسهم اذا ايضا ترى فقط مع اجراءات
من دولهم لاحظ ان مستوطن واحد مستعمر جاء
من البرلمان الاسرائيلي ووقف في وجه هذه
الوفود وفعليا دفعها للرحيل وانا اتساءل
لماذا لا تتخذ الدول الاوروبيه الان
اجراءات ضد ما تقوم به اسرائيل مثلا من
تدمير لمشاريع انشاتها هذه الدول باموال
دافعي الضرائب عندهم في مناطق جيم
الفلسطينيه على الاقل يستطيع ان يتخذوا
اجراءات في هذا الاتجاه يستطيع ان يتخذوا
اجراءات بمنع شامل لكل شيء له علاقه
بالمستوطنات والمستعمرات الاستيطانيه بفرض
العقوبات عليها ولكن حتى الان هناك تردد
وحتى كثير من الدول الاوروبيه التي تواصل
الحديث عن حل الدولتين حل الدولتين الذي
اصبح مجرد شعار لا تتجرا على الاعتراف
بفلسطين فبالتالي المطلوب هزه كبيره في
المجتمع الدولي لتغيير المسار ومره اخرى
اكرر لن ترد على الفاشيه الاسرائيليه
وهؤلاء المستعمرون الفاشيون الذين تجاوزوا
كل الحدود في اعتداءاتهم سواء في بورين او
حواره او زعتره او مسافر يطا او اي مكان
اخر لن يردعوا الا بمقاومتهم على الارض
وبفرض العقوبات والمقاطعه عليهم التحدي
الكبير الان على الصعيد الدولي هو ان تقوم
هذه الدول بفرض عقوبات على اسرائيل لن
ترضع اسرائيل الا بالعقوبات وانا اعتقد ان
الشعوب تريد فرض عقوبات وهناك حراك شعبي
عالمي الان لفرض العقوبات والمقاطعه على
اسرائيل لكن ذلك لم يترجم حتى الان على
مستوى الحكومات في انتظار ذلك هل يمكن ان
نطمع على الاقل في حمايه دوليه للمدنيين
كما طالب الوفد الاوروبي طالب بالحمايه
وهو مطلب فلسطيني قديم ايضا
هذا مطلب فلسطيني قديم
وقدم مرات عديده ولكن ايضا لم يتحقق لان
اسرائيل لا تسمح به
وكيف يمكن اجبار اسرائيل على السماح به
بتهديدها بالعقوبات
لاحظ انه حتى المجموعه التي كانت موجوده
كمراقبين فقط في منطقه الخليل بعد مجزره
الحرم الابراهيمي طردتهم اسرائيل في 24
ساعه ولم تقم الدول صاحبه الشان باتخاذ
اجراءات ضد ما قامت به اسرائيل لذلك انا
برايي يجب ان نرى مخالب مخالب المجتمع
الدولي مخالب القانون الدولي تستخدم
لاجبار اسرائيل على التراجع واجبارها على
توفير طبعا ان ياتي فعلا ان يكون هناك
حمايه دوليه للفلسطينيين لان الذين تعرض
له خطير جدا وما قاله سموتريتش هذا
المقفون الذي يريد ان ينسف وجود حواره
ومناطق اخرى ما قالوا هو يعكس في الواقع
التفكير
الاسرائيلي الحالي يحلمون بتكرار نكبه عام
يحلمون بتحقيق التطهير العرقي عندما تحدث
عن عن ازاله حواره هو هو كان يذكر يتذكر
ان العصابات الصهيونيه ازالت 530 بلده
وقريه فلسطينيه ولكن الشعب الفلسطيني
سيقاومهم ولا نسمح بتكرار هذه النكبه مره
اخرى شكرا لك دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي من رام
الله
ورغم حداثه عهد حكومه نتنياهو الجديده الا
ان الخطاب التحريضي ضد الفلسطينيين يتصدر
تصريحات اعضائها نتابع فيما يلي ابرز هذه
التصريحات والمواقف
منذ تشكيلها مطلع العام الحالي حملت
تصريحات لوزراء في حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو
عبارات تحريضيه ضد الفلسطينيين وممتلكاتهم
واراضيهم
مطلع هذا الشهر دعى وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي
الى محو قريه حواره في نابلس من الوجود لم
يكن هذا اول تصريح له على هذه الشاكله ففي
مطلع شهر فبراير وصف سموتريتش عائلات
الاسرى الفلسطينيين بانها عائلات الارهاب
في معرض اعلانه قرارا باقتطاع اموال كانت
تحولها السلطه الفلسطينيه لعائلات الاسرى
وزيره الدبلوماسيه العامه الاسرائيليه
وصفت الفلسطينيين بانهم قتلت مبرمجون لسفك
الدم اليهودي منذ الصغر وقالت ان الحرب
الدينيه لا بسبب الارض احد اكثر وزراء
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تطرفا
الذي يتولى حقيبه الامن القومي في اسرائيل
قاد اقتحاما لساحات المسجد الاقصى ولا
ينفك يكثف جهوده ضد الاسرى الفلسطينيين
ساعيا لتمرير قوانين تشجيز اعدامهم
[موسيقى]
القناه الثالثه عشره الاسرائيليه ان رئيس
هيئه الاركان الامريكيه المشتركه الجنرال
مارك ميلي وصل الى اسرائيل في زياره رسميه
واضافت المصادر سيعقد خلال زيارته هذه
سلسله من الاجتماعات الامنيه المهمه بشان
الملف النووي الايراني تمهيدا لزياره وزير
الدفاع الامريكيه اوستن الى المنطقه
الاسبوع المقبل
ليس سرا رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه
المشتركه مارك ميلي في اسرائيل لبحث
التنسيق لصد التهديدات التي تشكلها ايران
على حد تعبير بيان للبنتاجون زياره تاتي
على واقع تطورات في الملف النووي الايراني
بعد ان تحدث تقرير للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه عن جزيئات يورانيوم مخصبه بنسبه
تجاوزت ثلاثه 83% خلال زيارته التقى نظيره
الاسرائيلي هرتي هيلفي وفي اجندته كذلك
لقاءات مع وزير الدفاع
ورئيس جهاز المساد دافيد برنيه
زياره تستبق وصول وزير الدفاع الامريكي
الى اسرائيل الاسبوع المقبل وتاتي في جو
محتقن داخليا واقليميا بعد تقرير الوكاله
الدوليه عن اقتراب ايران من بلوغ العتبه
النوويه وهو السقف الذي وضعته تل ابيب
لنفسها قبل قرار توجيه ضربه للمفاعلات
النوويه الايرانيه يضاف الى هذا ما نقلته
هيئه البث الاسرائيليه عن مصادر امريكيه
واسرائيليه بشان سعي طهران لنيل منظومه
صواريخ اس 400 الروسيه وان ذلك قد يحفز
اسرائيل لتقريب موعد اتخاذ قرار قصف
المنشات النوويه الايرانيه
وهذه نقطه خلاف امريكي اسرائيلي اخرى فهو
شنط حسب تصريحاتها الرسميه ورغم تعطل
مساعي اعاده ايران للالتزام بالاتفاق
النووي ما تزال تشدد على اولويه
الدبلوماسيه كاستراتيجيه معتمده للتعامل
مع ايران فيما تبدي اسرائيل تشكيكا مستمرا
في هذا النهج وتؤكد ان توجيه ضربه لبرنامج
ايران النووي هو الحل الوحيد الكفيل بوضع
حد لما تقول انه طموحات طهران النوويه اما
اداره بايدن فتبقي سياسه الضغوط القصوى
التي ورثتها عن اداره ترامب مفعله وتقول
ان العقوبات واخرها ما اعلنته الخزانه
الامريكيه الخميس عن فرض عقوبات على شركات
شحن ايرانيه كفيله باعاده طهران الى
الاتفاق النووي لكن حسابات الزمن
الانتخابي الامريكي قد تجعل هذا الهدف
مؤجلا في وقت ترى فيه اسرائيل ان الزمن
يمضي بطيئا في الولايات المتحده وسريعا في
ايران المتهمه اسرائيليا
بالسعي لتطوير سلاح النووي وتتسع نقاط
الخلاف بين واشنطن وتل ابيب لتشمل التصعيد
الاسرائيليه تجاه الفلسطينيين حيث تصل
درجه التنديد الامريكي بالتصريحات
والسياسه الاسرائيليه الى مستويات غير
مسبوقه وسط امتعاد امريكي واضح من العناصر
اليمنيه المتطرفه في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
وسياساتها التحريضيه تجاه الفلسطينيين
قد نقلت مجله الامريكيه عن مسؤولين
امريكيه القول ان حصول ايران على نظام
الدفاع الجوي استا 300 او اس
400 الروسيه الصنع سيساعد في حمايه بنيتها
التحتيه النوويه من ضربات اسرائيليه
محتمله واضاف المسؤوله ان موسكو وطهران
قدمت بالفعل خطه لبناء مصنع لانتاج
المسيرات في روسيا وان ايران تضاعف الدعم
العسكري لروسيا عبر صفقات عسكريه جديده
يمكن ان تطيل الحرب في اوكرانيا وتوفر لها
شرايين حياه اقتصاديه ودفاعيه جديده في ظل
العقوبات المفروضه عليها واستنادا
للمسؤوله الامريكي فان روسيا تضع خطه
لتزويد ايران بمقاتلات ومروحيات وانظمه
دفاع جوي متطوره
معنى من تل ابيب مائيه
الاكاديميه والباحثه السياسي مع زياره
رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيين الجنرال
مارك ميلي ما المتوقع من هذه الزياره
[موسيقى]
برايي الشخصيه نحن لم نكن
قريبين الى الحرب بين ايران واسرائيل مما
نحن عليه الان نحن قريبون جدا من حرب بين
البلدين واعتقد ان الزيارات المتعدده هذه
ليست زياره واحده هنالك العديد من
الزيارات والمزيد من الزيارات من
من بين المسؤولين الامريكيين والمسؤولين
الاسرائيليين العسكريين مؤشر على انهم
يهيئون لهذا السيناريو لعده اسباب
استطاعتنا ربما نناقشها لاحقا ولكن هذه
الحرب القريبه بين ايران واسرائيل كما
تقول ربما ستعود الى قرار اسرائيلي وليس
الى تصعيد ايراني في هذه الحاله
بالنسبه لاسرائيل فان جمهوريه الاسلاميه
الايرانيه هي بدات بهذا التصعيد التصعيد
للموقف ايران هي تخصم اليورانيوم بنسبه
84% السبب الوحيد الذي يدفعك لتخصيب
اليورانيوم الى هذه النسبه هو
تهدف الى صنع قنبله النووي لا تحتاج الى
هذه النسب العاليه لانتاج الطاقه
الكهربائيه لكن لصراع قنبله هذا هو السبب
الاول ايضا هنالك سبب ثاني ان ايران لا
يبدو انها مهتمه بالعوده الى المحادثات
النوويه عندما نضع هذا الامرين سويه يخلق
هذا الامر سيناريو سيناريو ومنطق لاسرائيل
ان الديمقراطيه لن ان المفاوضات لن تنجح
ان ايران تقوم
بالتخصيب برسب عاليه فيتركنا هذا بخيار
واحد والخيار العسكري ولكن الكل يعلم سيد
جبدان ان قرار الحرب ضد ايران ليس قرارا
اسرائيليا هو قرار امريكي هو ضوء اخضر
امريكي وامريكا الان ليست في وارد ان تعطي
اسرائيل ضوء من هذا القبيل في هذه الظروف
الدوليه الحاليه
انا اختلف معك في هذه النقطه اعتقد ان
الرئيس بايدن قد ادرك ان الايرانيين ليسوا
راغبين بالعوده الى المحادثات النوويه
وهو قلق للغايه من احتماليه ايران النوويه
لسببين اولهما انه الامر هذا سيزيد من
زعزعه الاستقرار في المنطقه وهذا يعني ان
الولايات المتحده عليها ان تعود الى الشرق
الاوسط بينما الولايات المتحده تريد ان
تترك هذا الامر وتحدث الرئيس بايدن عن هذا
الامر السبب الثاني ان ايران النوويه
لان كل من هذين الدولتين هما حلفاء لايران
بسبب التاليه اعتقد ان بايدن يرى انه ليس
هنالك اي مجال للمفاوضات اعتقد ان انه
سيدعم هذه الضربه العسكريه المحتمله وهي
احدى الاسباب التي في اعتقادي اننا قريبون
من سيناريو الحرب شكرا
الان من طهران الدكتور عماد رئيس نقابه
مراكز الابحاث والدراسات في ايران اهلا
وسهلا بك دكتور أبشناز هل نحن فعلا على
ابواب حرب قريبه وفق هذا المنطق الذي كنا
نستمع اليه
تحياتي لك يا استاذ محمد
وللمشاهدين الاعزاء في الواقع انا اتصور
انه لو الامريكي والاسرائيلي
متاكدون من انهم يستطيعون ان يقوموا
بضربه عسكريه او هجوم عسكري
يكون نتيجته تدمير المنشات النوويه او
الاستراتيجيه الايرانيه او انهم لديهم
مثلا متاكدون من ان الهجوم على ايران
كلفته لن تكون اكثر من
الفائده اللي كانوا قد قاموا بهذا العمل
بالامس ولم ينتظروا اليوم
عمليا الامريكي والاسرائيلي يعلمون كلفت
مهاجمه المنشات النوويه الايرانيه او
البنى التحتيه الايرانيه على الولايات
المتحده وعلى اسرائيل ليس فقط الصهيوني
يعني الكيانه الصهيوني بنفسه ليس لديه هذه
القدره لكي يقوم باي عمل عسكري يعني هنا
نحن نتكلم عن عشرات المنشات المنتشره على
مليون و600 الف كيلومتر مربع ولا يمكن
الموضوع ليس يعني كما يصوره الاسرائيلي
كالهجوم الذي تم على منشات تموز في العراق
او في
المنشات النوويه في سوريا او ليبيا او
غيرها لا الموضوع مختلف كليا يعني نحن هنا
عندما نتكلم عن عشرات المنشات هنا تحتاج
العمل هكذا عمليه الى
مئات الطائرات كي يدخل الاجواء الايرانيه
بالتاكيد معظم هذه الطائرات لن يخرجوا من
الاجواء الايرانيه سوف يتم اسقاطهم ولربما
الذين يعودوا لن يجدوا اي مطار يحتضنهم
يعني بمجرد ان يدخلوا الاجواء الايرانيه
الايرانيون لن يجلسوا يعني مكتوب فوق اليد
اليد صواريخهم منتظره اللحظه المناسبه
مناسبه كي تنطلق على المنشات الاساسيه
الاسرائيليه
وحتى راينا ان الحرس الثوري هدد بانه سوف
يستهدف كل المنشات او القواعد العسكريه
الامريكيه ولكن عفوا
دكتور اذا وصلنا الى
سيناريو مخيف الى هذه الدرجه التي تتحدث
بها الان اسرائيل لن تكون بمفردها اذا
هاجمت اذا اذا جاء القرار بمهاجمه ايران
اسرائيل لن تهاجمها منفرده ستكون معها
الولايات المتحده بالتاكيد لا هي لن
واشنطن لن تفوض اسرائيل لوحدها بذلك
نعم وهذا ما اؤكده انا وانا لا اتصور ان
الامريكي سوف يسمح للاسرائيلي بهذا
الموضوع في الظروف الدوليه الحاليه لا
الامريكي ولا الاوروبي ولا حتى الدول
العربيه في المنطقه
يعني هي في وارد ان تفتح هكذا حرب في كل
المنطقه يعني تشتعل المنطقه ككل ولهذا انا
اتصور ان جميع اليوم يسعون
للوصول الى صيغه التفاهم
للعوده الى مفاوضات فيانا والتوقيع على
المسوده كل التصعيد الذي نشهده الان حاليا
هو في هذا السياق يعني عمليه
هنا
الامريكي يصعد الايراني يصعد التصعيد هذا
انا لا اتصور ان اي حتى ايران لا تريد
الحرب يعني الامر ليس من الطرف المقابل
فقط اسرائيل
تريد من الاخرين ان يقاتلوا بدلا عنها
شكرا لك دكتور عماد من طهران
ونبقى في هذه الاجواء فقد اجرى رئيس هيئه
الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه محمد اسلامي
الجوله الاولى من المباحثات مع المدير
العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
رافايا القروسي وياتي لقاء الجانبين في
طهران بعد ايام من تاكيد الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه ان مفتشيها عثر على جزئيات
من اليورانيوم مخصبه بنسبه تزيد على 80%
اي اقل بقليل من 90% اللازمه لانتاج قنبله
ذريه كما تاتي قبل اياما من اجتماع دوري
لمجلس حكام الوكاله الدوليه في فيينا
لمناقشه عده قضايا منها تطورات والبرنامج
النووي الايراني
[موسيقى]
الان الى ملف الحرب في اوكرانيا حيث افاد
موقع ريبار العسكري الروسي بان مجموعه
فاجنر التي تطوق مدينه
تقترب من قطع اخر طرق امدادات الجيش
الاوكراني في هذه المدينه الاستراتيجيه
حديث ياتي بعد تباين في وجهات النظر في
المعسكر الاوكراني بشان الموقف من
الانسحاب
في اطول معاركها منذ بدء حربها على
اوكرانيا تحاول القوات الروسيه منذ نحو
سبعه اشهر السيطره على مدينه باكموت
الاستراتيجيه شماليه مقاطعه
وسط مقاومه ضاريه من القوات الاوكرانيه
للحيلوله دون سقوط مدينه تعدها خط الدفاع
الاخير عن باقي المناطق التي لا تزال تحت
سيطرتها هناك لا سيما مدينه كراماتورسك
التحول الاهم في مسار القتال بمحيط باخ
موت في الاسابيع الاخيره جاء بعد ان رمت
ميليشيا فاجنر المجموعه العسكريه الروسيه
الخاصه بكامل ثقلها في اتون المعركه وتصدر
مقاتلها خطوط القتال الاماميه مع التركيز
على قطع كافه خطوط الامداد عن القوات
الاوكرانيه
المتحصنه وسطباخموت بالتزامن مع قصف لا
يهدؤ على مواقعها
يؤكد رئيس مجموعه فاغناريا في بروجين ان
باخموت اصبحت محاصره بشكل شبه كامل وان
هناك طريقا واحدا فقط بقي مفتوحا امام
القوات الاوكرانيه لكي تخرج من المدينه
بريكوجين دعا الرئيس الاوكراني الى سحب
قواته من هناك في اقرب وقت ممكن
اتوجه الى الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديميرنسكي
المحترم وحدات فاجنر العسكريه اصبحت تحاصر
بخمت بشكل شبه كامل ولم يبقى لهم سوى طريق
واحد والطوق يشتد حول المدينه
وقد انتقد الرئيس الاوكراني ما وصفها
بتنازلات تنازلات لدول اوروبيه لم يسميها
تجعل من الصعب تحقيق نصر سريعا لبلاده
وقال في مؤتمر الصحفي مع رئيس
يتجاوزون العقوبات ويساعدهم في ذلك دول
دول اعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي وفق
تعبيرهم
لا يمكن ان يكون هناك حل وسط بشان
العقوبات نرى كيف يتجاوزها الروس ومن
يساعدهم للاسف هناك دول اعضاء في الاتحاد
الاوروبي لا تتصرف بحزم واحيانا تقدم
تنازلات في بعض خطوات العقوبات هذا يجعل
تحقيق نصر سريع مستحيلا علينا ان نفعل ما
في وسعنا لمنع روسيا من انتاج هذه الكميات
من الاسلحه ومن المهم ان نضغط على الشركاء
في كل اوروبا وفي جميع انحاء العالم
ان الولايات المتحده والمانيا تتحركان
بقطن ثابته لتقديم المساعدات لاوكرانيا
وتقويه حلف شمال الاطلسي واضاف بيضا خلال
استقباله المستشار الالماني ان برلين قدمت
دعما وفيرا لاوكرانيا وقدمت دعما عسكريا
كبيرا لها من جهته قال ان عمل بلاده عن
كثب مع واشنطن من اجل تقديم المساعدات
لاوكرانيا كان مهما وانه بعث برساله
مفادها ان البلدين سيواصلان دعم اوكرانيا
مهما كلف الامر
تنضم الينا من البيت الابيض مراسلتنا وجد
وقفه اهلا بك وجد هذا الدعم المتواصل مهما
كلف الامر كيف تجسد في هذه اللقاءات
محمد يعني مهما كلف الامر ومهما استغرقت
هذه الحرب من وقت بحسب ما يؤكد دائما
الجانب الامريكي تحديدا الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن طبعا هذه المحادثات
استغرقت نحو ساعه والثلث المستشار
الالماني غادر قبل دقائق قليله من الان
وهي
ركزت على تنسيق شكل الدعم الذي سوف يقدمه
البلدان في المرحله المقبله من الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا وذلك يساعده
اوكرانيا على ما يقول الامريكيون او ما
يصفه البيت الابيض
بالنصر لاوكرانيا في هذه الحرب اذا تنسيق
شكل المساعدات في المرحله القادمه وفي
اطار الحديث عن المساعدات اليوم اعلنت
الاداره الامريكيه عن ارسال 400 مليون
دولار مجموع مساعدات جديده
اوكرانيا هذه الحزمه تضم في معظمها ذخيره
للدبابات المدرعات وكذلك لانظمه المدفعيه
التي تم ارسالها لاوكرانيا
واكثر من 30 مدرعه من الجانب الامريكي
الولايات المتحده حتى الان محمد ارسلت ما
قيمته اكثر من 30 مليار دولار من
المساعدات الامنيه
لاوكرانيا
وقبل نحو اسبوع فقط كانت قد اعلنت عن
ارسال مليارين دولار من المساعدات الامنيه
لاوكرانيا الاوروبيون من جانبهم حتى الان
ساهموا بنحو 20 مليار دولار من المساعدات
الامنيه لاوكرانيا هذه المساعدات كانت في
معظمها على شكل مدرعات اكثر من الف مدرعه
قدمتها دول اوروبيه لاوكرانيا واكثر وايضا
اكثر من 800 من انظمه المدفعيه
قدمها الجانب الاوروبي لاوكرانيا اذا
الحرب التي
حاليا تخوضها اوكرانيا ضد القوات الروسيه
تستند في معظمها على المساعدات من
الولايات المتحده وايضا من الدول
الاوروبيه لذلك جاء هذا الاجتماع في هذه
المرحله وذلك لتنسيق شكل الدعم في المرحله
المقبله من هذه الحرب محمد شكرا لك في من
واشنطن
[موسيقى]
تونس المحقنه سياسيا والمرهق اقتصاديا على
موعد مع احتجاجات ومظاهرات السبت والاحد
الاولى دعا اليها الاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل يوم السبت الثانيه بدعوه من جبهه
الخلاص المعارضه يوم الاحد للتنديد
بالاعتقالات التي طالت عده شخصيات في
البلاد معروفه بانتقادها لقرارات الرئيس
قيس سعيد وفي تعليقه على ترحيل نقابي
اسباني منع من دخول الاراضي التونسيه قال
الرئيس السعيد انه من حق اتحاد الشغل
تنظيمه مظاهره ولكن ليس من حقه دعوه اجانب
للمشاركه فيها
معارك اخرى موعوده في حرب اللات المتبادله
بين جبهه الخلاص المعارضه وتحدي الشغل من
جهه والسلطات التونسيه من جهه اخرى تونس
غير هادئه سياسيا عشيه المظاهره التي دعا
اليها الاتحاد العام للشغل والتي يفترض ان
تكون امام مقر النقابه السبق الامين العام
المساعد للاتحاد الحدث المنتظر بسلسله
اتهامات للحكومه على راسها اغراق المؤسسات
العموميه واغلاق باب الحوار
وتعطل التفاوض منذ اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر مع
رياده الحكومه ما علينا الا ان
نعبر عن احتجاجنا بالطرقيه استنكر الاتحاد
والترحيل السلطات الامنيه قياديا نقابيا
اسبانيا بعد وصوله الى مطار قرطاج مانعه
اياه من دخول الاراضي التونسيه كان يفترض
ان يشارك في المظاهره المرتقبه السبت وفي
تعليق على هذا القرار قال الرئيس التونسي
قيس سعيد ان الاتحاد حر في تنظيم مظاهرته
غدا لكنه ليس حرا في دعوه الاجانب
للمشاركه فيها وهذا امر غير مقبولا على اي
مقياس من المقاييس
لتكن معاملاتهم معهم كمؤسسات
ولكن تونس ليست ضيعه او بستانا تحدثت
وسائل اعلام تونسيه عن اعتقال عضوين اخرين
في حركه النهضه ويلاحق القضاء التونسي
المتهم بانهم مسيس نحو 20 معارضا من الصف
الاول بينهم ناشطون واعلاميون ورجال اعمال
وقيادي في جبهه الخلاص المعارضه تعتزم
الجبهه تنظيم مظاهره يوم الاحد للتنديد
بحمله الاعتقالات التي طالت قياداتها بين
ان والي العاصمه تونس قطعت طريق امامها
برفضه اصدار ترخيص لتنظيم المظاهره قائلا
ان شبهه التامر على امن الدوله مرتبطه
ببعض قيادي الجبهه وصفت الجبهه قرر المنع
بالتعسف والباطل مؤكده تحديها للسلطات
لتنظيم المظاهره دون ترخيص من جهتها دعت
حركه النهضه ان وكل القوى الحيه في البلاد
الى التظاهر السلميا يوم الاحد ونددت في
بيان بما سمتها محاولات التضييق وبث
البلبله منذ ان جمع الرئيس قيس سعيد
السلطات بيده عام 2021 وهو في عاصفه
الانتقادات والاتهامات بقمع الحريات
والتفرد بقرارات البلاد المصيريه تدهور
الوضع الاقتصادي وتردي المستوى المعيشي
ضاعف حاله النقمه والغضب لدى التونسيين
باختلاف ماربهم يدافع سعيدا عن نفسه
بالقول انما يفعله قانوني لانقاذ تونس من
الفوضى بعين غير راضيه عبرت اكثر من حكومه
غربيه ومنظمه دوليه عن قلقها من الوضع
الذي الت اليه الحريات وحقوق الانسان في
تونس في مقابله مع الجزيره تحدث الامين
العام للامم المتحده انطونيو غوتيريش عن
ضروره العمل من اجل الحفاظ على
الديمقراطيه في تونس مهد الربيع العربي
وقال ان الراي السياسي لا يبرر اعتقال احد
هل من مجيب صوت الخلافات هو الثابت في
المشهد التونسي المسخن بازمات مفتوحه على
كل الاحتمالات ما عدا الانفراج في
المستقبل القريب
تونس واما يجري فيها كانت ضمن ملفات سالت
عنها قبل الحصاد الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو الذي وجهت اليه اولا
سؤالا عن الاوضاع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله
سيد انطونيو العام للامم المتحده اهلا
وسهلا بكم
في الماضي اوتريت مقابلات في غرف صغيره
الان الاستوديو يعني تقدما رائعا اهنئكم
عليها اهلا وسهلا شكرا لك لو بدانا بالوضع
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله بلده حواره
تخضع للحصار لليوم السادس على التوالي هذا
الوضع وممارسات المستوطنين هناك تعرضت
للتنديد من عديد الدول من الولايات
المتحده من الامم المتحده ايضا
وسؤالي هو كيف تتابعون هذه الاوضاع في
الاراضي المحتله
انا اتابع ذلك ببالغي القلق انا اؤمن
ايمان صادقا بحل الدولتين واعتقد انه لا
توجد خطه بديله عن حل الدولتين اتذكروا في
الماضي عندما كنت رئيسا للوزراء في
البرتغال كان هناك في مكتبي اللقاء مع
شيمون ويصل عرفات ولعده سنوات
وبذلنا الجهود من اجل ان ينعقد السلام بين
فلسطين واسرائيل بلدين والقدس الدروس لم
تكونوا عاصمه
في التعايش في امن وامان للاسف نحن نعود
الى الوراء في هذا المشروع ومن الضروره
بمكان تجنب اي اجراءات احاديه المستوطنات
تخالف القانون الدولي وهي تقوض حل
الدولتين ايضا عمليات الطرب والان الحالات
الحالات الاعتداء التي الان بالعمليات
التي تسبب الكثيره من الالم نحن ضد اي عمل
ارهابي نحن ضد التحريض على العنص نحن نؤيد
حق الدوله اسرائيل في ان تعيشها بامن لكن
الامر نفسه يجب ان ينطبق على الشعب
الفلسطيني والشعب الفلسطيني الان يعانون
بطريقه مريحه هذا يقودنا الى سؤال قديم
جديد ومتجدد الى متى ستستمر اسرائيل كدوله
فوق القانون الدولي فوق القانون الدولي
ومحبيه فوق ذلك
لا يمكن ولا ينبغي ان يكون كذلك القانون
الدولي ينطبق على جميع لا توجد دول اكثر
مساواه من الاخرى من الضروره تماما ان يتم
احترام القانون الدولي من قبل الجميع
والامم المتحده واضحه بهذا الصدد الصدد
للاسف ما نراه حتى الان هو ان الكثير من
القرارات الامم المتحده لم تطبق والنظام
الدولي يفتقر الى الادوات التي يتم فيها
التطبيق القانون هذه واحده من المشكله
التي يعاني منها نظام الحوكمه الدولي وهذا
يعني من المبرر ان تكون هناك اصلاحات
لتجعل قانون دور الاكثر فاعليه سيدنا
الامين العام اكيد انكم سمعتم لكثير من
الاراء المتداوله في العالم العربي وهي
التي تشير الى يوصف هنا في المنطقه
بالنفاق الدولي في تعامل الامم المتحده
والمجت مع الدولي بين الوضع في اوكرانيا
والوضع في فلسطين هذا يتم تداوله باستمرار
حتى ان السفير موزمبيق وهو رئيس دوله مارس
في مجلس الامن الدولي عندما سئل هذا
السؤال تهرب منه هل يحرجك هذه هل تحرجكم
هذه المقارنه
امين عام انا ليس لدي النفاق او ازدواجيه
مع معايير لا انا ولا الامانه العامه لكن
اذا ما القينا نظره صادقه الى ما يقوم به
مجلس الامن الدولي والمجتمع الدولي في
كثير من تدخلاته ونشاطاته صحيح هناك
ازدواجيه معايير ليس فقط فيما يتعلق
باوكرانيا وفلسطين لكن هناك ايضا اوضاع
اخرى تخص البلدان الناميه بشكل عام تواجه
نظاما دوليا ونظام اقتصاديا ماليا دوليا
لا يتفق مع مصالحهم هنا لدينا ازدواجيه
معايير ايضا قدره المؤسسات الماليه
الدوليه للدعم
البلدان المتقدمه هي اكثر من قدرته على
دعم الدول النائمه نحن لا نعيش في عالم
نسوده العدل نعيش في عالم كثير من جوانب
الحاكم الدوليه تحتاج الى الاصلاح اصلاح
النظام اصلاح النظام التجاري اصلاح منظومه
الامم المتحده هناك الكثير من المجالات
تحتاج الى نظام الاكثر عدلا وهذه وهي من
الامور التي ادافع عنها بشكل مستمر من
واجب امين عام ان افعل ما استطيع من خلال
القدرات المتاحه لديه والتي ترتبط كثيرا
لكي تجعلني صوت الذين لا صوت لهم لكن هناك
امر واضح وهو اننا لا نمتلك نظام حوكمه
عالميه يستطيعوا التعامل مع المشكلات
الكبيره التي نواجهها المشكلات مثل مشكلات
فلسطين فقط بل حتى المشكلات العالميه مثل
الاحتباس الحراري تغيرات المناخيه وايضا
مع الامكانيات الكبيره والفوائد الكبيره
ما تزال هناك حقوق انسان مثلا تتعرض
للتقوير على نطاق واسع سيد قطيرش البعض
لاحظ في الكلمه التي
في مجلس الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان انه
عندما بداتم في سرد
الانتهاكات في عديد اماكن العالم اشرتم
الى الصين اشرتم الى ميانمار اشرتم الى
دول اخرى ولم تشير الى الممارسات
الاسرائيليه او الى فلسطين البعض لامكم
على ذلك وسال حتى السيد ستيفاندو جريك
فقال هذا ليس مقصودا اريد ان اسمع ردك انت
كلا كلا كلا المساله بسيطه انا كنت اتحدث
عن التقارير التي
يقدمها مفوض حقوق الانسان استنادا الى
قدراته وليس
للتفويض الذي بالنسبه
لفلسطين هو مفوض بذلك وهناك تقارير من عده
جهات تتعامل مع ذلك كان اذا ما كنت اتحدث
فقط هذا كان السياق مداخله النقاط التي
اشرتها من خلال هويه بناء على مبادره من
مفوضيه حقوق الانسان لم تتضمن فلسطين لان
التقارير حول فلسطين تقارير الزاميه
السؤال الاخير فيما يتعلق بالموضوع
الفلسطيني فيه كلمتكم امام مجلس الامن
الدولي في الذكرى الاولى
للغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا او حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا اشرتم الى اوضاع الاوكرانيين
فقلتم
حياتهم جحيم حقيقي تتحدث عن الاوكرانيين
لو طلبت منكم ان تصفوا حياه الفلسطينيين
ماذا تقولون
بكثير من الظروف هم ايضا يعيشون وضعا
جحيميا وان تعيش في غزه حيث لديك عدد كبير
من الناس في مساحه ضيقه تحت حصار مع نشاط
مع تهديدات ارهابيه من متعدده الانواع
الحياه في غزه في الحقيقه في كثير من
جوانبها
حياه جحيم اذا ليس لدي ازدواجيه معايير
هنا للاسف هناك اوضاع كثيره في العالم
يعيشوا فيها الناس في ظروف
دراماتيكيه وينبغي ان لا نحبط طرفا ضد اخر
انا على وجه الخصوص على وجه الخصوص معني
بوضع الشعب الفلسطيني
ولا احاول ان اغير من لهجه كلامي عندما
اتحدث عن وصفي مشكلاتهم انا واؤكد مره
اخرى اعتقد ان من الاهميه لمكان ان نجد
حلا حلا يستند الى حل الدولتين وان تكون
دروسا لم القدس كعاصمه لكلا البلدين تعيش
في امن وامان اسرائيل تحتاج الى الامر
الفلسطيني نحتاجون الى الامن ايضا لو سمحت
انتقل الى ما يجري في تونس ما يجري في
تونس جعل هذا البلد من بلد ملهم في عمليه
الانتقال الديمقراطي لمده عشر سنوات الى
بلد
ينتكس وبسرعه كيف تنظرون الى ما يحدث في
تونس خاصه مع موجه الاعتقالات ومع ما
يتعرض له المهاجرون الافارقه هناك من من
ممارسات بعد خطاب للرئيس قيس سعيد
ذلك بحق انا عايشت هذه الاحداث احداث
الربيع العربي للاسف في عده بلدان تحول
الربيع الى الشتاء طبعا الربيع العربي بدا
في تونس والديمقراطيه في تونس انا اعتز
بها وانظر بكثير من القلق الى تطور
الاوضاع لكن على رجل خصوص من المهم ان
نقول ان المهاجرين يجب ان يحضروا الحمايه
اينما كانوا مهاجرون حقوق الانسان وهذا
ينطبق على تونس كما ينطبق على اوروبا
واماكن اخرى في العالم وعندما اسمع ان
القاده السياسي يصفون المهاجرين بطريقه لا
تاخذ بعين الاعتبار احترامك كرامتهم
وحقيقه انهم بشر لهم حقوق حقوق انسان هذا
امر يشعرن بالصدمه العميقه يشعرني بالصدمه
العميقه في تونس وفي اوروبا وفي كل مكان
وبال الاوضاع حقوق الانسان هل لديكم قلق
خاص مما يجري من اعتقالات هناك
اعتقد ان واحده من الامور المهمه هو ان لا
ينبغي ان يسجن احد بسبب ارائه السياسيه
لا تبرر اعتقال اي شخص الناس يجب ان
يعتقلوا عندما يرتكبون الجريمه عندما
يهددوا يكونوا تهديدا للمجتمع وليس عندما
يعبرون عن وجهات نظرهم حتى لو كانت وجهات
النظر هذه مخالفه مع الحكومه او ايا كان
اي مؤسسه اخرى امل من ان الحوار سيسود
وامر من سيكون ممكنا لتونس في المستقبل ان
تكون ذلك البلد المنفتح الديمقراطي الذي
كلنا سعدنا
بتهنئتهم عندما كانت ايام الربي ع العربي
وظروفه قائمه الكل يتحدث عن ضروره عدم
تاسيس المساعدات التي تقدم في موضوع
الزلزال ولكن ما رايكم في من اعتبر هذه
المساعدات نوعا من الفرصه
للتطبيع مع الرئيس بشار الاسد وهو الذي
يخضع هو ونظامه لعقوبات دوليه طويله
مساعدات باي شكل من الاشكال الى حد ما نحن
ضحايا ذلك التسيس لكن علي ان اقول هنا ان
العقوبات لا يمكن ان تقوض الاستجابه
للزلزال انا طلبت في حاله جائحه كوفيد
وهذا ينطبق على سوريا كما ينطبق على اي
وضع اخر في العالم عندما ظهرت الجائحه
طالبت بتعليق العقوبات فيما يتعلق بشروط
ارجائها عندما حضر وقع الزلزال ايضا طلبته
تعليق العقوبات التي قد تؤخر الاستجابه
علينا ان نفصل تماما بين السياسه وما هي
ومن بين حاجات الناس الذين هم في حاله
معاناه الذين ينبغي ان نفعل كلما نستطيع
لانقاذهم بشكل مستقل عن من هو
مسيطر ويحكم المنطقه التي هم يعيشون فيها
شكرا جزيلا سيدي الامين العام للامم
المتحده السيد انطونيش على هذا اللقاء
شكرا لكم
بعدها سعاده البالغه نعود معكم واتمنى لكم
كل النجاح في عملكم واود ان اؤكد مره اخرى
ماذا اهميه
الامم المتحده اهميه حريه الصحافه نرى
الكثير من الصحافيين يتعرضوا قتل في العام
الماضي 50% اكثر من العام الذي قبل انتم
ايضا مررتم بحادثه شيرين التي قتلت وارد
ان اعبر عن التزامي العميق بحريه الصحافه
وتضامن مع كل الصحفيين في كل انحاء العالم
الذين يضحون بحياتهم لكي نحصل نحن على
المعلومات الصحيحه
تغطيتنا مستمره لاهم احداث العالم نلتقي
بكم بعد الفاصل قصير
[موسيقى]
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه وهذا
التفكير باهم العناوين في حصاد الليله
في توسيع لهجماتهم المستوطنون يستهدفون
بورين في نابلس وفد اوروبي يطالب من داخل
حوار بحمايه الفلسطينيين ومسائله
المهاجمين الاحتلال يمنع نشطاء فلسطينيين
واجانب من دخول البلده يقول للجزيره ان
الفلسطينيين يعانون جحيما وتهديدا لحياتهم
والمفوض السامي لحقوق الانسان يتهم
الاحتلال بتعمد استخدام القوه المميته
مع اقتتام منابرات اسرائيليه امريكيه
تحاكي ضرب منشات نوويه ايرانيه رئيس هيئه
الاركان الامريكيه في تل ابيب والبنتاجون
يقول انها تشمل تنسيق التصدي لما سماه
تهديدات ايران ومسؤول امريكي يتحدث عن سعي
ايراني للحصول على منظومه اس 400 الروسيه
لحمايه منشاتها من اي عمل اسرائيلي
معارك السيطره في شرق اوكرانيا تحتدم
فاجنر تقول انها تحاصر مدينه الاستراتيجيه
وتطالب القوات الاوكرانيه بالانسحاب منها
بايدن يبحث مع المستشار الالماني تعزيز
دعم اوكرانيا والبيت الابيض يكشف عن
مساعدات عسكريه جديده
يهاجم الاصوات الاوروبيه المعارضه
للعقوبات على روسيا
[موسيقى]
عشيه احتجاجات جديده لقطاعاته النقابيه
الاتحاد الشغل في تونس يتهم الحكومه
باغلاق ابواب المفاوضات وجبهه الخلاص
تتمسك بمظاهرات الاحد رغم المناعه الرئيس
سعيد يرفض اشراك الاجانب في اي مظاهرات
ويجدد المطالبه بالمحاسبه والامم المتحده
تدعو لحمايه الديمقراطيه في تونس وتجدد
رفض اعتقاد اي شخص بسبب ارائه السياسيه
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
قريه بورين في الضفه الغربيه تمثل احدث
فصول هجمات المستوطنين فقد قال مسؤولهم
الى فلسطين في شمال الضفه الغربيه غسان
دغلس ان عشرات المستوطنين هاجموا منازل في
القريه واعتدوا على سكانها بالرشق
بالحجاره كما اطلقوا الرصاصه الحي في
الهواء مع الحق اضرارا بعدد من البيوت وقد
اكدت مصادر الطبيه فلسطينيه عدم وقوع
اصابات خلال تلك الاعتداءات
وقبل ايام من بورين كانت حواره وما زالت
عنوانا لاقتحامات قوات الاحتلال وهجمات
المستوطنين وقد زار وفد من الاتحاد
الاوروبي ودبلوماسيون بلده حواره ودانوا
جرائم المستوطنين واجراءات الاحتلال فيها
وطالب الوفد الاوروبي خلال جوله ميدانيه
شملت قريه زعتره بمحاسبه المسؤولين عن تلك
الجرائم في حق الفلسطينيين
الى بيت الشهيد سامح الاقطش في قريه زعتره
الجنوبيه نابلس جاء وفد الاتحاد الاوروبي
في اولى محطات جولته الميدانيه للوقوف عن
قرب على ما تعرضت له العائله من جريمه قتل
احد ابنائها برصاص المستوطنين الاحد
الماضي
الوفد الاوروبي اصطدم بهذه المشاهد في
بلده حوار المجاوره عشرات المنازل احرقت
ومئات المركبات لم يتبقى منها سوى هياكلها
الخارجيه
وخلال الزياره تعرض الوفد الاوروبي وممثله
مؤسسات حقوقيه لمحاولات التشويش من احد
المستوطنين
ذات بالنسبه لنا من المهم تحقيق المسائله
الكامله واحضار المعتدين الى العداله
والذين تعرضوا للخساره في ممتلكاتهم يجب
تعويضهم والاكثر اهميه هنا يجب وقف عنف
المستوطنين لانه اذا استمر ذلك فلن يكون
هناك مستقبل في هذا المكان اذ لا توجد
حمايه للفلسطينيين المدنيين ولا يمكن
العيش بسلام وحريه
وتزامنا مع الزياره قمعت قوات الاحتلال
مظاهره ناشطي سلام اسرائيليين ومنعتهم من
الوصول الى بلده حواره للتضامن مع سكانها
يجب ان يكون هناك موقف واضح وان يقول
مجتمع الدولي بمحاسبه اسرائيل على هاي
الجرائم وهذه هي يعني بين قوسين مستطيل
ولكن الاساس هي الدوله اللي راعت هذا
الارهاب لدعمت هذا الارهاب واللي حمدت هذا
الارهاب بنيرانها وبمعداتها وقوف الوفد
الاوروبي على شهادات ضحايا جرائم
المستوطنين واجراءات الاحتلال العسكريه في
قريه زعتره وبلده حواره وما تحمله تلك
الجرائم من مشاهد تستدعي في نظر
الفلسطينيين تدخلا فوريا لحمايتهم واذا
كانت زيارته فود دوليه تاتي مؤقتا فان
الفلسطينيين يودعون شهدائهم بشكل شبهي
يومي
[موسيقى]
فقد شيعت جماهير بلده عزون في محافظه
قلقيليه جثمان الشهيد الفتى محمد سليم الى
مثواه الاخير تشييع صاحبه تمديد بجرائم
الاحتلال ومستوطنيه التي تستهدف الحجر
والبشر في جميع الاراضي الفلسطينيه دون
حسيب او رقيب سمير ابو شمالي الجزيره من
بلده حواره جنوبيه نابلس فلسطين
وفي مقابله مع الجزيره قال الامين العام
للامم المتحده انطونيو انه لا بديل عن حل
الدولتين وان على الجميع ادى كذلك مشيرا
الى ان الفلسطينيين يعانون جحيما وتهديدا
لحياتهم
ان على المجتمع الدولي التحرك بقوه لضمان
ان يحظى القانون الدولي بكل الاحترام
من الواضح ان حل الدولتين يعني انهاء
الاحتلال وقرارات الامم المتحده تنص على
ذلك لكن المجتمع الدولي ليس قادرا على
تطبيقها وهذه مشكله في نظام الحوكمه الذين
نعيشه هو نظام بلا مخالب وحتى ان وجدت هذه
المخالب كما هو الحال عن طريق مجلس الامن
فليست هناك اراده لاستخدامها وتطبيق
القانون بالقوه يجب ان نتحرك بقوه اكبر في
المجتمع الدولي لضمان ان يحظى القانون
الدولي بالاحترام
هذا وقد قال المفوض السامي لحقوق الانسان
التابعه للامم المتحده فولكرتونغ ان قوه
الامن الاسرائيليه استخدمت القوه المميته
ضد الفلسطينيين بشكل متكرر ووصف ترك خلال
اجتماعا لمجلس حقوق الانسان الوضع في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله بالماساوي
بالنسبه الى الفلسطينيين
ان الوضع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
ماساه ماساه للشعب الفلسطيني قبل كل شيء
ادى الاحتلال المستمر منذ اكثر من نصف قرن
الى اتساع نطاق نزع الملكيه وتعميق
الحرمان والانتهاكات المتكرره والخطيره
لحقوقهم بما في ذلك الحق في الحياه لا
يمكن لاحد ان يرغب في العيش بهذه الطريقه
او يتخيل ان اجبار الناس على العيش في
ظروف يائسه كهذه يمكن ان يؤدي الى حلا
دائم
وينضم الينا من
رئيس بعثه الاتحاد الاوروبي الى مصر
والاردن سابقا والمستشار السابق في دائره
العمل الخارجيه للاتحاد الاوروبي اهلا
وسهلا بك السفير مورن هل هناك ما يمكن ان
يقوم به الاتحاد الاوروبي في اجواء مثل
هذه بالنسبه للفلسطينيين
لقد راينا ممثل الاتحاد الاوروبي مع
يذهبون الى الموقع ويدينون
الاحداث وراينا ايضا
تصريح وتصريح وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي والذي هو يعتبر مرفوضا من قبل
الجميع السؤال هو هل
هل سيكون هنالك تطبيق للعداله بالتاكيد
لما حصل في السابق لا يقترح ذلك اعتقد ان
منظمات حقوق الانسان في فلسطين قامت
بتوثيق اكثر من 90 حادثه وتحقيق من قبل
المستوى الصينيين منذ سنوات عديده لكن لم
ينتج عنها اي شيء بالتالي لا اعتقد اننا
نستطيع ان نكون متفائلين في هذا الامر اذا
ما استمر هذا الامر اعتقده ان الاوروبا
وايضا اعضاء مجلس الدولي يجب ان يصعدوا من
ضغوطهم على اسرائيل يعني كيف يمكن ان يكون
هذا التصعيد مثلا
اكرر سؤالي ربما لم يصل تفضل
بالتاكيد هنالك اعتماد كبير من اسرائيل
على على التجاره
المرنه والسهله مع الاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا
مع اطراف اخرى هنالك ايضا من البرامج التي
يتم
التعاون بين اسرائيل والاتحاد الاوروبي
فيها اذا لم يقم السيد نتنياهو باتخاذ
خطوات ملموسه قد يتم انهاء هذه البرامج
يعني تعتقد انه اذا لم تكن هناك عقوبات
اوروبيه موجهه لاسرائيل فقد لا تتغير
السياسه الاسرائيليه
علينا ان نرى اذا ما كان هنالك جديه من
الجانب
الاسرائيليه لتحقيق العدل كما قلت التاريخ
لا يقترح ذلك يجب ان يكون عندما نرى الى
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اعتقد انها حكومه
ملتزمه بسلام على العكس من ذلك لكن الى ان
نعرف
بالمزيد عن الخطوات التي
تتخذها اسرائيل علينا ان ننتظر ونرى هنالك
اجراءات تستطيع اوروبا واطراف اخرى ان
تقوم بها من اجل ان تحسن من وضع الامور
الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي كانت لها دائما في
الاغلب مواقف معينه من المستوطنات ومن
التعامل مع البضائع المصدره من المستوطنات
حتى بتمييزها بالكتابه وغير ذلك هل هل
يمكن اتخاذ اجراءات اكثر
شده في هذا المجال
اعتقد انها يجب ان تقوم بذلك هنالك موقف
واضح على المستوى الاوروبي على هذه
المنتجات ومعظم الدول الاوروبيه ايضا قامت
بتبني هذه الامور واتخاذ اجراءات عديده قد
تكون
اقل
فعاليه فيما يتعلق بالبضائع المصنعه في
المستوطنات لكن اعتقدوا اننا يجب ان نعيد
النظر بهذه العلاقات التجاريه وخاصه في ظل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده شكرا جزيلا
لك يا سفير جيمس مورن من
[موسيقى]
اعلنت القناه الثالثه عشره الاسرائيليه ان
الرئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه المشتركه
الجنرال مارك ميلي وصل الى اسرائيل في
زياره رسميه واضافت المصادر انمي سيعقد
خلال هذه الزياره سلسله من الاجتماعات
الامنيه المهمه بشان الملف النووي
الايراني تمهيدا لزياره وزير الدفاع
الامريكيه اوستنون الى المنطقه الاسبوع
المقبل
ليس سرا رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه
المشتركه مارك ميلي في اسرائيل لبحث
التنسيق لصد التهديدات التي تشكلها ايران
على حد تعبير بيان للبنتاجون زياره تاتي
على واقع تطورات في الملف النووي الايراني
بعد ان تحدث تقرير للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه عن جزيئات يورانيوم مخصبه بالنسبه
تجاوزت ثلاثه وثمانين في المئه خلال
زيارته التقى نظيره الاسرائيلي هرتز وفي
اجندته كذلك لقاءات مع وزير الدفاع
ورئيس جهاز المساد دافيد بارنيا
زياره تستبق وصول وزير الدفاع الامريكي
الى اسرائيل الاسبوع المقبل وتاتي في جو
محتقن داخليا واقليميا بعد تقرير الوكاله
الدوليه عن اقتراب ايران من بلوغ العتبه
النوويه هو السقف الذي وضعته تل ابيب
لنفسها قبل قرار توجيه ضربه للمفاعلات
النوويه الايرانيه يضاف الى هذا ما نقلته
هيئه البث الاسرائيلي عن مصادر امريكيه
واسرائيليه بشان سعي طهران لنيل منظومه
صواريخ اس 400 الروسيه وان ذلك قد يحفز
اسرائيل لتقريب موعد اتخاذ قرار قصف
المنشات النوويه الايرانيه
وهذه نقطه خلاف امريكي اسرائيلي اخرى
فهواشنطن حسب تصريحاتها الرسميه ورغم تعطل
مساعي اعاده ايران للالتزام بالاتفاق
النووي ما تزال تشدد على اولويه
الدبلوماسيه كاستراتيجيه المعتمده للتعامل
مع ايران فيما تبدي اسرائيل تشكيكا مستمرا
في هذا النهج وتؤكد ان توجيه ضربه لبرنامج
ايران النووي هو الحل الوحيد الكفيل بوضع
حد لما تقول انه طموحات طهران النوويه اما
اداره بايدن فتبقي سياسه الضغوط القصوى
التي ورثتها عن اداره ترامب مفعله وتقول
ان العقوبات واخرها ما اعلنته الخزانه
الامريكيه الخميس عن فرض عقوبات على شركات
شحن ايرانيه كفيله باعاده طهران الى
الاتفاق النووي لكن حسابات الزمن
الانتخابي الامريكي قد تجعل هذا الهدف
مؤجلا في وقت ترى فيه اسرائيل ان الزمن
يمضي بطيئا في الولايات المتحده وسريعا في
ايران المتهمه اسرائيليا
بالسعي لتطوير سلاح النووي وتتسع نقاط
الخلاف بين واشنطن وتل ابيب لتشمل التصعيد
الاسرائيليه تجاه الفلسطينيين حيث تصل
درجه التنديد الامريكي بالتصريحات
والسياسه الاسرائيليه الى مستويات غير
مسبوقه وسط امتعاد امريكي واضح من العناصر
اليمنيه المتطرفه في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
وسياساتها التحريضيه تجاه الفلسطينيين
نقلت مجله الامريكيه عن مسؤول امريكيه
القول ان حصول ايران على نظام الدفاع
الجوي اس 300 او اس 400 الروسيه سنه
سيساعد في حمايه بنيتها التحتيه النوويه
من ضربات اسرائيليه محتمله واضاف المسؤوله
ان موسكو وطهران قدمته بالفعل خططا لبناء
مصنع لانتاج المسيرات في روسيا وان ايران
تضاعف الدعم العسكري لروسيا عبر صفقات
عسكريه جديده يمكن ان تطيل الحرب في
اوكرانيا وتوفر لها شرايين حياه اقتصاديه
ودفاعيه جديده في ظل العقوبات المفروضه
عليها واستنادا للمسؤوله الامريكي فان
روسيا تضع خططه لتزويد ايران بمقاتلات
ومروحيات وانظمه دفاع جوي متطوره
انضموا الينا الان من واشنطن الدكتور علي
واعد مدير مشروع ايران في مجموعه الازمات
الدوليه اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور وعد في ظل
هذه الاجواء المتعدده الاوجه ما المتوقع
من زياره جروسي الى طهران
الامل ان المدير اغراسي سيتمكن من حل بعض
القضايا المتعلقه بنشاطات ايران النوويه
حقيقه انه كان هنالك اثار لتخصيب
اليورانيوم بنسبه 84% وهي نسبه تقترفه من
اليورانيوم الذي
ضروري لصناعه
قنبله وايضا مساله اكتشاف
اجهزه طرد مركزيه لم يتم الاعلان عنها
هنالك امل ان هناك سيتم هنالك حل لهذه
القبائل بوجود المحققين الاضافيين بدون اي
شيء لن يتم حل المشاكل بين ايران والوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الداريه في هذه الزياره
تحديدا هذه الزياره هي الرابعه وتاتي
دائما في الغالب قبل اجتماع لمجلس
المحافظين في فيينا هل تتوقع جديدا في
اجتماع ديانا في ضوء هذه الزياره
اذا لما تاتي هذه الزياره بالتقدم الذي
كان يعمله المدير غراسي فاعتقد ان من
المحتوم للغرب ان يكون هنالك قرار مركزي
ضد ايران في مكتبي
في مكتبه في عفوا في مجلس الحكامه الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه المشكله هي انه
هنالك اقتراب كبير الى مساله
التخصيب الضروريه للاسلحه وهذا ربما سيؤدي
الى ربما سيؤدي الى تصعيد في الموقف
باكملهم هذه زياره تتضمن لقاء بين جروسي
والرئيس الرئيسي
لقاء على هذا المستوى الا يمكن ان يحرك
الامور بشكل افضل
ليس بالضروره ليس الامر لا يتعلق الامر
بالرئيس الرئيسي كما اظهر في السابق انه
لا يمتلك فهما حقيقيا للموقف هذا قرار
منهجي في ايران اذا ما كان هنالك قرار ان
الموقف حساس للغايه وايضا خطوره المواجهه
العسكريه بين ايران والولايات المتحده
واسرائيل في مستويات على ربما سيكون هنالك
ربما تقليل التوتر عن طريق الموافقه على
الاقل بعمليات تحقيق اضافيه وبالتوافق مع
المدير الكروزي لكن اذا ما ارادوا
استفزازات اضافيه مع او بدون الاجتماع
سيحدث هذا الامر باي حال من الاحوال
التقارير تشير الى ان واشنطن تتريث في
اتخاذ اي موقف في انتظار نتائج هذه
الزياره على عكس مواقف اوروبيه تبدو اكثر
تشددا كيف سيؤثر ذلك على قرارات الوكاله
في المستقبل
مجلس مجلس
الحكام وعاده الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي سيكون ذلك ربما تنسيق
لكن اعتقد ما سيحدث ان عليهم جميعهم ان
ينتظروا نتيجه او قرار المدير جروسيه حول
زيارته وما التقدم الذي تم احرازه ام له
بعد ذلك سيتم ربما اتخاذ قرار باخذ قرار
مركزي اخر قرار تم اتخاذه قبل ثلاثه اشهر
بالتالي ليس هنالك ضروره ملحه لاصدار قرار
الان حول التقدم لكن اذا لم يكن لديك اي
تقدم اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده ستنضم مع
الاوروبيين في تقديم لهذا القرار المركزي
لكن كما قلت الامر لن ياتي مجانا ايران
دائما سيكون لها رد وبالاخذ بنظر الاعتبار
الوضع الحالي فان مساله
الخطا في الحسابات هي احتماليه عاليه شكرا
لك دكتور علي واعظ من واشنطن
قد اجر رئيس هيئه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه
محمد اسلامي الجوله الاولى من المباحثات
مع المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رافايا الجروسيا ياتي لقاء
الجانبين في طهران بعد ايام من تاكيد
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ان مفتشيها
عثروا على جزئيات من اليورانيوم مخصبه
بنسبه تزيد على 80% اي اقل بقليل من 90%
اللازمه لانتاج قنبله الذريه كما تاتي
قبيل ايام من اجتماع دوري لمجلس حكام
الوكاله الدوليه في فيينا لمناقشه عده
قضايا من بينها تطورات البرنامج النووي
الايراني
[موسيقى]
الى ملف الحرب في اوكرانيا حيث افاد موقع
ريبار العسكريه الروسي بان مجموعه فاجنر
التي تطوق مدينه باخموت تقترب من قطع اخر
طرق امدادات الجيش الاوكراني في هذه
المدينه الاستراتيجيه حديث ياتي مع بروز
تباين في المعسكر الاوكراني بشان الموقف
من الانسحاب
في اطول معاركها منذ بدء حربها على
اوكرانيا تحاول القوات الروسيه منذ نحو
سبعه اشهر السيطره على مدينه باكموت
الاستراتيجيه شماليه مقاطعه
وسط مقاومه ضاريه من القوات الاوكرانيه
للحيلوله دون سقوط مدينه تعدها خط الدفاع
الاخير عن باقي المناطق التي لا تزال تحت
سيطرتها هناك لا سيما مدينه كراماتورسك
التحول الاهم في مسار القتال بمحيط باخ
موت في الاسابيع الاخيره جاء بعد ان رمت
ميليشيا فاجنر المجموعه العسكريه الروسيه
الخاصه بكامل ثقلها في اتون المعركه وتصدر
مقاتلها خطوط القتال الاماميه مع التركيز
على قطع كافه خطوط الامداد عن القوات
الاوكرانيه
المتحصنه وسطباخموت بالتزامن مع قصف لا
يهدؤ على مواقعها
يؤكد رئيس مجموعه فاغناريه
اصبحت محاصره بشكل شبهي كامل وان هناك
طريقا واحدا فقط بقي مفتوحا امام القوات
الاوكرانيه لكي تخرج من المدينه
بريكوجين دعا الرئيس الاوكراني الى سحب
قواته من هناك في اقرب وقت ممكن
اتوجه الى الرئيس الاوكراني فلادي المحترم
وحدث فاجنر العسكريه اصبحت تحاصر بخمت
بشكل شبه كامل ولم يبقى لهم سوى طريق واحد
والطوق يشتد حول المدينه
على الجانب الاوكراني بدت الرسائل متضاربه
ففي الوقت الذي اعلن فيه قائد اللواء
الميكانيكي الثامن والعشرين بالجيش
الاوكراني يوري ماديار ان وحدته
الاستطلاعيات تلقت امرا بالانسحاب من
باخموت اكدت القوات البريه في الجيش
الاوكراني ان قائدها زار المدينه واستمع
الى تقارير القاده الميدانيين بشان مسار
القتال هناك كما اطلع على القضايا
الاشكاليه المتعلقه بزياده القدره
الدفاعيه للوحدات في الخطوط الاماميه
وسواء انعكست هذه التطورات خلافا داخل
المعسكر الاوكراني اما انها مجرد تكتيكات
ميدانيه فان اخر المعلومات القادمه من
باخموت تفيد بان قتالا شرسا لا يزال يدور
على المحور الشمالي للمدينه حيث يقع ما
يمكن وصفه بالشريان الاخير للقوات
الاوكرانيه القادر على ضخ تعزيزات عسكريه
لها تحول دون سقوط المدينه بيد المقاتلين
الروس
هذا وقد انتقد رئيس الاوكراني
وصفها بتنازلات لدول اوروبيه لم يسميها
تجعل من الصعب تحقيق نصر سريع لبلاده في
مؤتمر الصحفي مع رئيس لدفيا اجلس في لفيف
غربيه اوكرانيا قال ان الروسي يتجاوزون
العقوبات ويساعدهم في ذلك دول اعضاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي وفق تعبيرها
جهود
لا يمكن ان يكون هناك حل وسط بشان
العقوبات نرى كيف يتجاوزها الروس ومن
يساعدهم للاسف هناك دول اعضاء في الاتحاد
الاوروبي لا تتصرف بحزم واحيانا تقدم
تنازلات في بعض خطوات العقوبات هذا يجعل
تحقيق نصر سريع مستحيلا علينا ان نفعل ما
في وسعنا لمنع روسيا من انتاج هذه الكميات
من الاسلحه ومن المهم ان نضغط على الشركاء
في كل اوروبا وفي جميع انحاء العالم
في هذه الاثناء قال الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدون ان الولايات المتحده والمانيا
تتحركان بخطا ثابته لتقديم المساعدات
لاوكرانيا وتقويه حلف شمال الاطلسي بايدن
اضاف خلال استقباله المستشاره الالماني
ان برلين قدمت دعما وفيرا لاوكرانيا وقدمت
لها دعما عسكريا كبيرا من جهه قال ان عمل
بلاده عن كثب ما هواشون من اجل تقديم
المساعدات الى اوكرانيا كان مهما وانه بعث
برساله مفادها ان البلدين سيواصلان دعم
اوكرانيا مهما كلف الامر
[موسيقى]
سباقا للمظاهر المتوقعه على الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل قال الرئيس التونسي قيس
سعيد ان الاتحاد حر في تنظيم مظاهره السبت
لكنه ليس حرا في دعوه الاجانب للمشاركه
فيها
هناك من يريد ان يبدو بعض الاشخاص الاجانب
للتظاهر في تونس
وهذا امر غير مقبولا على اي مقياس من
المقاييس
لتكن معاملتهم معهم كمؤسسات
ولكن تونس ليست ضيعه او بستانا او ارضا
بلا سيد
معارك اخرى موعوده في حرب اللاتات
المتبادله بين جبهه الخلاص المعارضه
واتحاد الشغل من جهه والسلطات التونسيه من
جهه اخرى تونس غيرها سياسيا عشيه المظاهره
التي دعا اليها الاتحاد العام للشغل والتي
يفترض ان تكون امام مقر النقابه السبق
الامين العام المساعد للاتحاد الحدث
المنتظر بسلسله اتهامات للحكومه على راسها
اغراق المؤسسات العموميه واغلاق باب
الحوار
وتعطل التفاوض منذ اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر مع
رئاسه الحكومه ما علينا الا ان نعبر عن
احتجاجنا بالطرق سلميه استنكر الاتحاد
والترحيل السلطات الامنيه قياديا نقابيا
اسبانيا بعد وصوله الى مطار قرطاج مانعه
اياه من دخول الاراضي التونسيه كان يفترض
ان يشارك في المظاهره المرتقبه
تحدثت وسائل اعلام تونسيه عن اعتقال عضوين
اخرين في حركه النهضه ويلاحق القضاء
التونسي المتهم بانه مسيس نحو 20 معارضا
من الصف الاول بينهم ناشطون واعلاميون
ورجال اعمال وقيادي في جبهه الخلاص
المعارضه تعتزم الجبهه تنظيم مظاهره يوم
الاحد للتنديد بحمله الاعتقالات التي طالت
قياداتها بين ان والي العاصمه تونس قطعت
طريق امامها برفضه اصدار ترخيص لتنظيم
المظاهره قائلا ان شبهه التامر على امن
الدوله مرتبطه ببعض قيادي الجبهه وصفت
الجبهه قرر المنع بالتعسف والباطل مؤكده
تحديها للسلطات لتنظيم المظاهره دون ترخيص
من جهتها دعت حركه النهضه انصارها وكل
القوى الحيه في البلاد الى التظاهر
السلميا يوم الاحد ونددت في بيان بما
سمتها محاولات التضييق وبث البلبله
منذ ان جمع الرئيس قيس سعيد السلطات بيده
عام 2021 وهو في عاصفه الانتقادات
والاتهامات بقمع الحريات والتفرد بقرارات
البلاد المصيريه تدهور الوضع الاقتصادي
وتردي المستوى المعيشي ضاعف حاله النقمه
والغضب لدى التونسيين باختلاف ماربهم
يدافع سعيد عن نفسه بالقول انما يفعله
قانوني لانقاذ تونس من الفوضى بعين غير
راضيه عبرت اكثر من حكومه غربيه ومنظمه
دوليه عن قلقها من الوضع الذي الت اليه
الحريات وحقوق الانسان في تونس في مقابله
مع الجزيره تحدث الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو غوتيريش عن ضروره العمل
من اجل الحفاظ على الديمقراطيه في تونس
مهدي الربيع العربي
اعتقد ان المهم هو ان لا يسجن اي شخص بسبب
ارائه السياسيه الراي السياسي لا يبرر
اعتقال احد يجب ان يعتقل الناس عندما
يرتكبون جرائم او يهددون المجتمع وليس
عندما يعبرون عن ارائهم حتى وان كانت هذه
الاراء تخالف توجهات الحكومه هل من مجيب
صوت الخلافات هو الثابت في المشهد التونسي
المسخن بازمات مفتوحه على كل الاحتمالات
ما عدا الانفراج في المستقبل القريب
انضموا الينا من تونس العاصمه احمد
النفاتي نائب رئيس حزب العمل والانجاز
المنضوي تحت لواء جبهه الخلاص الوطني ومن
مدينه سوسه الساحليه في شرق البلاد قيصر
الصياح المحامي والباحث القانونيه اهلا
بضيفين نبدا بالسيده النفاتي مظاهره اتحاد
الشغل يوم السبت مظاهره جبهه الخلاص يوم
الاحد ما الذي تضيفه المظاهرتان للمشهد في
تونس
السلام عليكم جميعا يعني من احد اهم
مكتسبات الثوره هي حق التظاهر السلمي
والتعبير الحر عن الراي وهذا الذي ناظر من
اجله يعني كل الاجيال وهذه من اهم
المكتسبات اليوم يضرب هذا المكتسب وهناك
حاله تطور خطير لحاله الحريات
في يعني منع جبهه الخلاص من التظاهر يوم
الاحد يعني خاصه بعد ان قامت الجبهه باكثر
من 20 تظاهر سلميا وعبرت فيها يعني عن
شعارات سياسيه وهي مناهضه للنظام هي يعني
معارضه للنظام وفي الحاله في الفتره
الاخيره هناك عمليه تصفيه للرموز السياسيه
المعارضه للنظام يعني منذ فتره هناك عمليه
تخوين واولاد عمليه تهديد لكل المحتكرين
والكل الذين تسببوا في تجويع الشعاب من
رجال الاعمال الفاسدين وفساد المحتكرين
في لحظه من الزمان تطفو علينا يعني قضيه
التامل على امن الدوله وهي مبنيه على مجرد
وشايات
[موسيقى]
بقضيه باسم اكس اكس التي اصبحت نكته اليوم
يتداولها ابناء الشعب التونسي وثم نجد
السياسيين والمعارضين في السجون لم نجد
محتكرين لم نجد فاسدين وجدنا معارلين
يحاكمون بقانون الارهاب
ان هذا القانون هم الذين صاغوه بايديهم
ولكن وجدوا انفسهم بايديهم في عشريه
الثوره ولكن مع الاسف بعد 25 جويليا وجد
هذه القيادات السياسيه التي تبنت العمل
السلمي منذ عهد بن علي وفيهم حتى منذ عهد
بورقيبه تحاكم على قانون الارهاب الذين
صاغوه بايديهم بالرغم انهم لم يرفعوا
السلاح في الدوله هذه الاجواء يعني بعد
اذنك سيدنا فاتى هذه الاجواء
سيد قيصر السياح اعطت انطباعا دوليا بان
الحريات في تونس تزداد اختناقا حتى ان
انطونيو تيرش
اعرب عن ذلك في مقابلته مع الجزيره اعرب
عن قلق الامم المتحده من هذه الاجواء في
تونس الى اي مدى هناك وعي لدى القياده في
تونس
بخطوره مثل هذا المسار
مساء الخير شكرا تحيه لك
ليست المره الاولى التي تحدث فيها سياسي
اجنبي او ممثل اممي عن القلق وعن الفزع من
موضوع المحاكمات المدنيه والعسكريه في
تونس ونتذكر جيدا من العام المساعد مكلف
بالعداله بالشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
عندما زارت تونس سنه 2012 قال نحن قلقون
جدا وظل هذا القلق يتمادى الى عشرات سنين
والى حد الان بخصوص ما يسمى بالاعتقالات
التعسفيه او المحاكمات الغير العادله هذا
من باب اولي من باب ثاني الاعتقالات هذه
جاءت في سياق تطبيق القانون ولم تكن ابدا
تحت غطاء او تحت وطاه التوظيف السياسي
الذي يريد البعض ان يذيله في هذا السياق
ويجعل منه منها قضيه سياسيه بامتياز او
قضيه سياسيه بامتياز انشائنا باعتبار اننا
اما انا صاع الى تطبيق القانون ونكون ضمن
سياده الدوله وسياده نفاذ وانفاذ القانون
كما موجود في فرنسا لها وكمات لانفاذ
القانون والعديد من الدول الاخرى ثالثا
الاعتقالات لم تشمل فقط السياسيين ونحن
يعني نلاحظ منذ مده كيف ان شق من المعارضه
وليس كل السياسيين في تونس باعتبارنا لنا
112 حزب في تونس الان المعركه ولي ذراع
وكسر العظام مع ست احزاب فقط تقريبا من
طيف سياسي كله والاعتقالات شامله رجال
اعمال من الصف الاول ينادي ينادي
المواطنين منذ مده ايقافهم ونتذكر جيدا
على راسهم اكبر رجل الاعمال في تونس وتسعى
قياديين من قياده العليا بوزاره الداخليه
يعني ليسوا خصوم لقيس سعيد الامنين ولكن
اسمح لي سيد صياح اسمح لي السيد صياح انت
انت رجل قانون وباحث ومحامي
في مثل هذه القضايا عندما نرى
محاضر الابحاث ونرى طبيعه التهم الموجهه
اصبحت محل تندر يعني هي كل القضاه
وكل المحامين يؤكدون بانها ملفات فارغه
ومع ذلك هناك ضغط كبير من السلطه السياسيه
لادانه هؤلاء حتى قبل ان يثبت القضاء
ادانتهم او هذه مساله غير معهوده لا في
عهد بورقيبه ولا في عهد بن علي
لم نسمع ولو قاضي واحد بتونس سواء من
جمعيه القضاه التي ينبغي تحتها القضاه او
نقابه القضاه المحترمه كذلك او المجلس
الاعلى للقضاء الذي هو الضامن الوحيد الان
الاستقلاليه وحياه القضاء ان قال ان
الملفات فارغه
مثلا على سبيل المثال الدكتور القاضي احمد
سواب على سبيل المثال ليس الحصر القاضي
احمد سواب
استهزا كثيرا بهذه الملفات وبهذه
التحقيقات
القاضي القاضي السابق المحترم السيد احمد
والان المحامي اولا وهو ينوب حتى بعض من
الاشخاص من الرجال الاعمال الموقوفين الان
ويعرف هذا القاسي والداني وسيد احمد هو
واحد من 9,200 محامي في تونس نحن ضد
الاقافات والتعسفات وضد الاخلالات في
الاجراءات باعتبار ان الماده الجزائيه هي
ماده اجراءات بامتياز ونحن نعتبر وصلنا
احنا عديد المرات ان المتهم
سواء في القانون التونسي او في المواثيق
الدوليه والسقوق المعاهدات هناك ايضا بعد
اذنك هناك ايضا مساله اخرى اسال عنها في
النهايه السيد احمد النفااتي
مظاهره اتحاد الشغل السيد سامي الطاهري
رحب باي منضمين لها من بين الذين
يتبنون نفس المطالب وجبهه الخلاص ايضا دعت
ما سمتهم بكل القوى الحيه هل هل نحن امام
توسع
مدروس لقاعده المتظاهرين
طبعا هو اتحاد الشغل هي منظمه وطنيه فيها
كل العائلات السياسيه وهي منظمه وطنيه من
اكبر المنظمات والاعلى في المنظمات
الوطنيه وكان لها دور كبير في عديد
المحطات يعني منذ الاستقلال ومنذ ما قبل
الاستقلال يعني نزول عندما يدعو اتحاد
الشغل الى التظاهره
فهذا تنزل كل العائلات السياسيه اذا تب
نت واتوقع ان في مظاهرات الاتحاد ستلبي
يعني كل الاحزاب كل السياويه يعني كل
الشخصيات الوطنيه وكل السياسيين غير
الانضمام الى هذه المظاهره تحت مظله اتحاد
الشغل لان المطار بمطالب وطنيه بالاساس
شكرا جزيلا لك سيد احمد النفاتي من تونس
شكرا لك سيد قيصر الصياح من سوسه
[موسيقى]
وقعت تركيا ودوله الامارات العربيه
المتحده اتفاقيه شراكه اقتصاديه الشامله
سيتم بموجبها الغاء الرسوم الجمركيه او
الغائها عن ثلاثه وتسعين بالمئه من
المبادلات التجاريه غير النفطيه بين
البلدين وبذلك تصل قيمتها الى 40 مليار
دولار خلال السنوات الخمس المقبله وقال
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في اتصال
بالرئيس الاماراتي الشيخ محمد بن زايد ان
الاتفاقيه ستعزز الصداقه والتعاون الثنائي
وشكل دوله الامارات على دعمها لبلاده بعد
زلزال السادس من فبراير شباط الماضي من
جانبه قال رئيس دوله الامارات ان اتفاقيه
الشراكه الاقتصاديه الشامله مع تركيا خطوه
نوعيه في مسيره علاقات البلدين وانها
ستعزز التعاون الاقتصادي والتجاري
دعت الارجنتين بريطانيا الى بدء محادثات
جديده بشان السياده على جزر الفوركلاند
الارخبيل المتنازع عليه في جنوب المحيط
الاطلسي وزاره الخارجيه الارجنتينيه اعلنت
الخميس عن خطط لاعاده النظر في مطالبتها
بالجزر المعروفه باسم جزر ملك
في ناس باللغه الاسبانيه وقالت الوزاره في
بيان لها عقب اجتماعا مع مسؤولين
بريطانيين ان وزير الخارجيه
صاغتراحا لاستئناف المفاوضات من اجل
السياده على جزره
في فقره المتابعه ستكون لنا عوده لقضيه
فوكلاند لنضعها في سياقها التاريخي
ونستطلع مع ضيفنا افاق التوتر بشانها بين
لندن وبيونس
[موسيقى]
التسعى نطاق واستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي في
الصين ليشمل مجالات التعليم والنقل
والدفاع الالكتروني والتصنيع العسكري بعد
ان كان مقتصرا على قواعد البيانات وهندسه
الكمبيوتر والبرمجه وتسعى بجين الى
الرياده في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي المتقدم
بحلول عام 2030 لتتجاوز منافسها الاكبر في
هذا المجال الولايات المتحده
الدفع بنظام التعرف على الوجه مشهد بات
مالوفا في الصين مع انتشار استخدام
التكنولوجيا المتقدمه في مناحي الحياه
كافه غير ان القلق الامريكيه من الاستخدام
الصيني لمثل هذه التقنيات يكمن في مجال
اخر الذكاء الاصطناعي المتقدم
يعد عام 2016 تاريخا مفصليا في تطور
الذكاء الاصطناعي حين هزم كمبيوتر شركه
جوجل الامريكي بطل العالم في لعبه الصينيه
ولان عدد الخطوات المحتمله في هذه اللعبه
التي تشبه الشطرنج غير محدود فان تحفيظ
الكمبيوتر خطوات مسبقا امر محال لكن من
خلال تقنيه التعلم المتعمق امتلك
الكمبيوتر ذكاء اصطناعيا يمكنه من التعلم
الذاتي وابتداع خطوات لم يفكر فيها
الانسان
الذكاء الاصطناعي المتقدم هو ان تكون
الاله قادره على تعليم نفسها تماما كما
نفعل نحن البشر وذلك يعتمد على مجموعه
كبيره من البيانات والمعلومات المدخله
وعليه نستطيع القول ان هذا المستوى من
التعلم الالي يمكن ان يتفوق على الذكاء
البشري لعل الصين ادركت حين هزمها
الكمبيوتر الامريكي في لعبتها التي تعود
الى اكثر من
2500 سنه ان عليها اللحاقه بركب تطوير
الذكاء الاصطناعي المتقدم بل ان تسعى الى
ان تصبح رائده في هذا المجال بحلول عام
2030 تبلغ قيمه الاستثمار في سوق الذكاء
الصناعي الصيني اكثر من 23 مليار دولار
ومن المتوقع حسب مختصين ان يتجاوز الرقم
150 مليارا بحلول عام
2030 كما حصلت الشركه الناشئه في مجال
الذكاء الصناعي على دعم حكومي بلغ 17
مليار دولار العام الماضي وتعتبر شركه
بايتو احدى الشركه الرائده في هذا المجال
بنحو 46 الف موظف تستحوذ بايتو على سوق
الذكاء الاصطناعي المتقدم في الصين وتمتلك
محرك البحث الاول في البلاد منذ انشائها
عام 2000 خلال العقدين الاخيرين طورت
بيدوس 57 تطبيقا يسمح لها بالوصول الى
بيانات نحو مليار مستخدم للانترنت في
الصين اضافه الى تصنيع السيارات ذاتيه
القياده واشباه الموصلات لتصبح المنافس
الاول لشركات امريكيه مثل تسلا
يلقى تطوير الذكي للصناعي المتقدم دعما
ضخما لاهميته في صناعه السيارات الذكيه
ومجال الطاقه والكهرباء كما اننا ننتج
الجيل الثاني من الرقائق الالكترونيه التي
تستخدم في تشغيل السيارات ذاتيه القياده
ونظرا الى غياب القوانين الصارمه بشان
الخصوصيه يعد الوصول الى كميه هائله من
البيانات احد العوامل التي تمنح الصين
ميزه تنفسيه كبيره في سوق الذكاء الصناعي
اما العامل الثاني فيتمثل في تطوير رقائق
الكترونيه قادره على تحليل ملايين
البيانات بسرعه فائقه وهي اشباه الموصلات
القادره على القيام بثلاثمائه عمليه في
الثانيه والتي حضرت الولايات المتحده
بيعها للشركات الصينيه خشيت استخدامها في
التكنولوجيا العسكريه كالتعرف على الصوت
والوجه والتجسس
اعتقد ان الصين تملك بدائل بعض العقوبات
الامريكيه ضد شركات مثل هواوي وزي تي اي
التي تهدف الى قطع امدادات احدث الرقائق
الالكترونيه في الصناعات الاستهلاكيه
والعسكريه لكن الصين قادره على تطويرها
ولديها اكبر عدد من خريج الهندسه
التكنولوجيه والرياضيات
المواجهه التكنولوجيه بين الصين والولايات
المتحده مفتوحه في ساحه عده ومنها المجال
الطبي لكن اهم هذه الساحات واخطرها هي
المجال العسكري وفي هذا السياق حددت الصين
هدفا لبناء جيش متطور تكنولوجيا عام 2027
تكون اولويته التفوق على الولايات المتحده
شيماء شووي الجزيره
ومن واشنطن الدكتور ماثيو برينج الاستاذ
بجامعه جورج تاون ومؤلف كتاب عوده التنافس
بين القوى العظمى ونبدا من ضيفنا في
واشنطن
هذا التنافس الصيني الامريكي ما حظوظ
الطرفين فيه
الولايات المتحده هي كانت الرائده في
التكنولوجيا في العالم لاكثر من مئه عام
واعتقد انها ما تزال كذلك وهي لديها افضل
الجامعات الصين من الجانب الاخر هي
بالتاكيد حاولت الى حاقه بركب الولايات
المتحده لكنها ما تزال خلفها كان قد افضل
المتخصصين في التكنولوجيا في الصين تدربوا
في الولايات المتحده والكثير من المكاسب
التي احرزتها الصين كانت عن طريق سرقت
الملكيه الفكريه الان الولايات المتحده
وحلفاءها يحاولون ان يصدوا هذا الامر
ويضعوا بعض
التقييد حول الممارسات التي التي تتبعها
الصين في مجال التكنولوجيا بالتالي في شكل
نهائي فان الولايات المتحده ستستمر بكونها
الرائده في هذا المجال هل معنى ذلك دكتور
بان واشنطن لا تشعر بقلق بهذا الموضوع
تجاه الصين
التطبيقات الصينيه للتكنولوجيا قد تكون
مقلقه للولايات المتحده مثلا الصين تستخدم
الذكاء الاصطناعي من اجل الاعتراف عفوا
تحديد هويه الشخص والتجسس وهذه
التكنولوجيا انتشرت بشكل كبير وكان لها
تاثير سيء على حقوق الانسان والانظمه
الديمقراطيه ايضا الصين تحرز مكاسب عسكريه
مثلا تكتنولوجيا الفائقه الصوت الصواريخ
فاقد الصوت بالتالي هذه الولايات المتحده
قلقه من بعض التطبيقات التكنولوجيه وهي
تتخذ خطوات من اجل الدفاع عن نفسها
وحلفائها السيد
لماذا كل هذه الشكوك
تجاه الصين فيما يتعلق بهذه التكنولوجيا
اعتقد اهلا ومرحبا بكم اعتقد ان هذا
اللقاء كي ياتي من الولايات المتحده وكذلك
هناك
النظريات التحديثات الصينيه الان الرائده
في الولايات المتحده
ولايات المتحده تعتبر الصين اكبر منافس
استراتيجي وتحديد لها فاي عمل يقوم بها
الصين تشك بها ولان هذه
يعني
العوامل السياسيه
وكذلك يعني بحجه يعني الافراد في امن
الامن القومي فلذلك الولايات المتحده لا
تريد ان تتعاون مع الصين في هذا المجال
وتريد ان تبقى المتفوقا على الصين
وتعمل كلما قوسها لاحتواء التطور الصيني
في مجال التكنولوجيا ما اشار اليه ضيفنا
من امريكا السيده وان
فيما يتصل بامكانيه الجوسسه واختراق
الخصوصيه في الصين فضلا عن ان هناك بعض
التقنيات سرقت كما يقول من من الولايات
المتحده كيف يمكن الرد حول هذه النقاط
اولا هناك التقدم كبير في
مجال حمايه ملكيه الفكريه وكذلك
تحتها من كثيرا باداره
هذه
الملكيه الفكريه وكذلك اداره
التقدم استخدام التكنولوجيا
وكذلك الصين تعارض يعني اي اي حي من في
التكنولوجيا وكذلك الحدث الثاني هو ان
تخدم التقدم التكنولوجيا
وتميتها لتخدم رفحيه
يعني البشريه وتخدم الحياه الافضل للبشريه
السيد الدكتور كرون في في واشنطن
هذا التنافس هل يلغي بالكامل ايه امكانيه
في المستقبل لتعاون امريكي صيني او تنسيق
في هذا المجال
يعتمد على القرارات التي يتم اتخاذها في
بيجين خلال العقود الماضيه فان الولايات
المتحده قامت باكثر من اي دوله ممكنه من
اجل مساعده الصين في المجال التكنولوجي
هنالك الكثير من المحاولات للتعاون
والكثير من المتخصصين في التكنولوجيا
الصينيه درسوا في الولايات المتحده وتاتي
الكثير من التكنولوجيا
الصينيه من تكنولوجيا لشركات امريكيه تم
نقلها الى هناك والولايات المتحده ولسنوات
كانت
راغبه بالقبول بذلك لان هذا الامر ربما قد
يساعد الصيفي ان تصبح اكثر تعاونا واكثر
ديمقراطيه لكن الان الرئيس هي اتخذ اخذ
الصين بوجهه مختلفه بالتالي الولايات
المتحده له ليست راغبه بعد الان في ان
تقوم بذلك وتحاول ان تدافع عن نفسها اذا
الصين تحركت باتجاه مختلف
لكن اذا مصيته حركه باتجاه مختلف وك انت
متعاونه اكثر مع جيرانها واوقفت تهديدها
للجيران اعتقد ان هنالك ربما سيكون فرصه
للتعاون بين الصين والولايات المتحده لكن
كما قلت هذا يتطلب تغيير لمقاربه الصين
تجاه العالم
هل يمكن ان تمضي الصين في هذا الاتجاه
حول التعاون طبعا الصين منفتحه جعلت
منفتحه لحد التعاون دائما للتعاون في كل
المجالات ليس فيها مجال تكنولوجيا فحسب
فهناك يعني فجوه وما زال هناك
الولايات المتحده في هذا المجال والصين
يعني السبب التفوقها والتقدمها الكبير في
هذه السنوات الاخيره هو ان الصين يعني
منفتحه على التعلم والدراسه لذلك الصين
ايضا تدعو الى التعاون مع الولايات
المتحده وتعلم منها لاجل التقدم المشتركه
والاستحار مشتركه
وبدلا من المواجهات مع الولايات المتحده
شكرا جزيلا لك سيد رانجوان من بيجين شكرا
لك دكتور ماثيو جرينج من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
نعود الان لموضوع الفولاندي نلقي نظره على
جغرافي هذا الارخبيل الذي تسميه الارجنتين
مال فينس او المال يقع على بعد 600 كيلو
متر قبالته السواحل الارجنتين تعرف
المملكه المتحده تعرفها تعرف جزر الفوكلان
باعتبارها اقليما خارجيا يتمتع بالحكم
الذاتي اعلنت كل من المملكه المتحده
والارجنتين منذ فتره طويله سيادتها على
هذا الارخبيل مع وصول التوتر الى نقطه
تحول في الثمانينات بدخول البلدين حربا
بسببه اظهر استفتاء في فوكلاندا عام 2013
دعما واسعا النطاق لبقائها تحت السياده
البريطانيه احتفلت الدولتان العام الماضي
بالذكرى الاربعين للصراع الذي اود بحياه
649 جنديا ارجنتينيا
و255 جنديا بريطانيا في الجزيره
تنضم الينا من واشنطن سونيا شوت الخبيره
في شؤون امريكا اللاتينيه نرحب بها
ونسالها ما اذا كان هذا النزاع سيعود من
جديد الان ويفرض نفسه على الساحه الدوليه
اعيد السؤال اسال عن هذا النزاع ما اذا
كان سيعود الان بقوه
مع مع ابتسامه الضيفه الجميله مع ذلك لم
نتلقى الجواب لا ادري اين هو الاشكال هل
علي ان اعيد السؤال ام انتظر الجواب
ساعيده مره اخرى للمره الثالثه
هذا النزاع بين الارجنتين والمملكه
المتحده فيما يتعلق بالفوكلاند هل سيعود
الان بقوه على الساحه الدوليه
بدايه اعتقد ان الحكومه الارجنتينيه
هم انسحبوا من هذا الاتفاقيه في عام 2016
ويحاولوا ان يجبروا الحكومه البريطانيه ان
يفوضوا مره اخرى علينا ان نتذكر ان الامم
المتحده واللجنه الخاصه بالاستعمار ما
تزال تعتبر ان هنالك اختلاف واضح ومفتوح
بين الارجنتين والمملكه المتحده اعتقد ان
الارجيل الارجنتين تحاول ان ربما تبنيه
الاسس للمطالبها
من جهه اخرى علينا ان ناخذ بالحسبان انه
كان هنالك في عام 2013
وفي كان هنالك استفتاء وفي الجزر هنالك
قرروا ان يبقوا الحال على ما كان عليه
وتحت
الاداره البريطانيه
لكن
لماذا هذا الصراع مهم بدايه دعونا نتحدث
عن الاسباب الاقتصاديه ان المنطقه غنيه
جدا بالموارد الطبيعيه
وهنالك سفن من كل انحاء العالم من اسيا
وايضا من اسبانيا ودول اوروبيه اخرى تقوم
بدفع ملايين الدولارات
سنويا من اجل حقي ان تقوم بعمليات الصيد
في تلك المنطقه وعلينا ايضا ان ننظر بنظر
الاعتبار ان هذا الحديث بعد فتره الجائحه
وعن التضخم بالتالي الاسباب الاقتصاديه
مهمه للغايه
لكلاءتين
للمملكه المتحده وللارجنتين ايضا لكي
تستعيد هذه الجزر وفعلا الموضوع مهم
للدولتين شكرا لك سيده سونيا سكوت من من
واشنطن
بدات محاله تجزئه في لبنان تسعير المواد
الغذائيه بالدولار بدلا من الليره وقد اكد
وزير الاقتصاد في حكومه تصريف الاعمال
اللبنانيه امين سلام ان التسديد الفواتير
سيبقى بالليره اللبنانيه وفق سعر صرف
الدولار في السوق
غالبيه هذه السلع لم تعد في متناول
اللبنانيين
يقفون حائلين امام الاسعار بعد قرار
السلطات تسعير المواد الغذائيه بالدولار
وفق سعر صرف السوق السوداء
هذه مناعه
ولكن ماسيا لبنانيين تتجاوز تامين الغذاء
الى كل ما يفترض ان يكون من بديهيات العيش
موقفه بس على الاكل والشرب طب ما في دواء
في طبابه في اللي عنده مريض اللي عنده
دواء شو بيعمل
تتقلب اسعار السلع والخدمات من وقود
واتصالات وغيرهما وفق سعر الدولار فالسعر
الذي يسجله صباحا قد ينخفض خلال النهار
ليستعد صعوده مساء فيما تكمن المعضله في
عدم قدره مديريه حمايه المستهلك على ضمان
رقابه شامله على الاسعار ولهذا الواقع
الاقتصادي تبعات بنيويه على المجتمع
اللبناني
سنكون امام طبقه فاحشه الثراء وطبقه معدمه
وحين يختل التوازن بعدم وجود طبقه متوسطه
نكون امام انتاج صراع طبقي جديد كان ينعكس
ليس على مستوى الاقتصاد الاجتماعي المالي
فقط قد ينعكس ايضا على المستوى الامني
وهنا اتكلم عن الامان الاجتماعي
رقعه الدولره لتشمل مختلف القطعه في لبنان
وهو ما يعزز خشيه الخبراء من ارتفاع نسبه
التضخم وتعميق معاناه لبنانيين فالمماطله
في اعتماد حل اقتصادي شامل تطيل الازمات
وتجعل الاتفاق مع صندوق النقد الدولي
بعيدا عن الاتفاق بيجي بيعمل بسد هيدي
الفجوه بالدولار وبالتالي بيعمل شيء
استقرار بسعر الصرف ولكن نحن بعدنا بعد عن
هيدي اللحظه الاسباب المعروفه اللي هي في
خلافات جوهريه حاول تنفيذ الشروط المسبقه
للاتفاق مع صندوق النقد قصدي اقول انه
قدامنا بعد مسار من الالام والجلجل فيما
خص التسعير وازاء الدوله التي شبه الشامله
في لبنان تم 8 يرى ان هذه الخطوه تتجاوز
البعض النقدي وتشكل انتقاصا للسياده
الماليه للدوله وقدرتها على التحكم في
اقتصادها
باتت حياه اللبنانيين مضبوطه على تقلبات
سعر صرف الدولار فالمواطنون يرون في
القرارات الرسميه نوعا من الفوضى في ظل
غياب خطه شامله تعيد لهم حقوقهم في الغذاء
والتعليمي والعلاج كارمنج خضار الجزيره
بيروت
بهذا نصل الى نهايه الحصاده الان على راس
الساعه ونشر مع محمد مزيمس